everyone welcome to this live tensorflow
and keras tutorial from simplylearn
in this tutorial we will teach you all
that you need to know about tensorflow
and keras
we will start with tensorflow a low
level deep learning python api
we will first take a look at some deep
learning frameworks and then we'll
answer the question
what is tensorflow following this we
will look at some features
and applications of tensorflow we will
then see how tensorflow works and look
at some comparisons between tensorflow 1
and 2
and then we'll take a look at the
architecture of tensorflow and
end it with a hands-on demo following
the tensorflow tutorial we will move on
to keras
a high-level deep learning python api
which works on top of tensorflow
we will start with answering the
question what is
keras then we will look at the working
principle of keras
we will look at models which are offered
by keras and what neural networks are we
will start with answering the question
what is keras then we will look at the
working principle of it
we will look at models offered by keras
and what neural networks are
we will then start with our keras demo
where we will look at data
pre-processing
implementing and training neural
networks and predicting with them
we will end this tutorial with the
hands-on mini project
on mass detection where we will be using
tensorflow and keras to find out if a
person is wearing a mask in real time
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to simply learn and hit the
bell icon to never miss an
update welcome to tensorflow tutorial
what's in it for you we're going to
cover today deep learning frameworks
what is tensorflow features of
tensorflow tensorflow applications
how tensorflow works tensorflow 1.0
versus 2.0
tensorflow 2.0 architecture and then
we'll go over a tensorflow
demo where we roll up our sleeves and
dive right into the code
so let's start with deep learning
frameworks
to start with this chart doesn't even do
the
filled justice because it's just
exploded
these are just some of the major
frameworks out there there's a cross
which happens to sit on tensorflow so
they're very integrated
there's tensorflow pie torches out there
cafe piano dl4j
and chainer these are just a few of the
deep learning frameworks
we're talking about neural networks if
you're just starting out never seen a
neural network you can go into python in
the
scikit and do the neural network in
there which is probably the most
simplest version i know
but the most robust version out there
the most top
of the ladder as far as the technology
right now is tensorflow
and that of course is changing from day
to day and some of these
are better for different purposes so
let's dive into tensorflow
let's see what is tensorflow what is
tensorflow
tensorflow is a popular open source
library released in 2015 by google brain
team
for building machine learning and deep
learning models
it is based on python programming
language and performs
numerical computations using data flow
graphs to build models
so let's take a look at some of the
features of tensorflow
it works efficiently with
multi-dimensional arrays
if you've ever played with any of the
simpler packages of neural networks
you're going to find that you have to
pretty much flatten them and
make sure your your stuff is set in a
flat model
tensorflow works really good so we're
talking pictures here
where you have uh x and y coordinates
where the picture is and then
each pixel has three or four different
channels
that's a very complicated array very
multi-dimensional array
it provides scalability of computation
across machines and large
data sets this is so new right now
and you might think that's a minor thing
but when
python is operating on one computer and
it has a float value
and it truncates it differently on each
computer you don't get the same results
and so your training model might work on
one machine and then another it doesn't
this is one of the things that
tensorflow addresses and does a very
good job on it supports fast debugging
and model building this is why i love
tensorflow
i can go in there and i can build a
model with different layers
each layer might have different
properties they have like the
convolutional neural network which you
can then sit on top of
a regular neural network with reverse
propagation there's a lot of tools in
here and a lot of options
and each layer that it goes through can
utilize those different options and
stack differently
and it has a large community and
provides tensorboard
to visualize the model tensorboard is
pretty uh
recent but it's a really nice tool to
have so you when you're working with
other people or showing your
clients or the shareholders in the
company
you can give them a nice visual model so
they know what's going on what are they
paying for
and let's take a glance at some of the
different uses or applications for
tensorflow when we talk about tensorflow
applications
uh clearly this is data analytics we're
getting into the data science i like to
use data science is probably a better
term because this is the programming
side
uh and it's really the sky is a limit we
can look at face detection
language translation fraud detection
video detection there are so many
different things out there that
tensorflow can be used for
when you think of neural networks
because tensorflow is a neural network
think of complicated chaotic data this
is very different
than if you have a set numbers like
you're looking at the stock market
you can use this on the stock market but
if you're doing something where the
numbers are very clear
and not so chaotic as you have in a
picture then you're talking more about
linear regression models
and different regression models when
you're looking at that when you're
talking about these really complicated
data patterns
then you're talking neural networks in
tensorflow and if we're going to talk
about tensorflow we should talk about
what tensors are
after all that is what tensor um that's
what this is named after so we talk
about tensors in tensorflow
tensorflow is derived from its core
component known as a tensor a tensor is
a vector or a matrix of n dimensions
that represent all types of data and you
can see here we have the scalar which is
just a single
number you have your vector which is two
numbers might be a number in a direction
you have a simple matrix and then we get
into the tensor
i mentioned how a picture is a very
complicated tensor because it has your x
y coordinates and then each one of those
pixels
has three to four channels for your
different colors and so each image
coming in
would be its own tensor and in
tensorflow tensors are defined by
a unit of dimensionality called as
rank and you can see here we have our
scalar which is a single number that has
a rank of zero because it has no real
dimensions to it other than it's just a
single point
and then you have your vector which
would be a single list of numbers
so it's a rank one matrix would have
rank two
and then as you can see right here as we
get into the full tensor
it has a rank three and so
the next step is to understand how a
tensorflow works
and if you haven't looked at the basics
of a neural network in reverse
propagation
that is the basics of tensorflow and
then it goes through a lot of different
options and properties that you can
build into your different tensors
so a tensorflow performs computations
with the help of data flow graphs
it has nodes that represent the
operations in your model
and if you look at this you should see a
neural network going on here we have our
inputs bc and d and you might have
x equals b plus c y equals d minus 4
a equals x times y and then you have an
output
and so even though this isn't a neural
network here it's just a simple set of
computations going across
you can see how the more complicated it
gets the more because you can actually
one of the
tensors is a neural network with reverse
propagation
but it's not limited to that there's so
much more you can do with it
and this here is just a basic uh flow of
computations
of the data going across and you can see
we can plug in the numbers
b equals four c equals three d equals
six and you get x equals four plus three
so x equals seven y equals six minus
four so y equals two
and finally a equals seven times two or
a equals fourteen
like i said this is a very simplified
version of how tensorflow works
each one of these layers can get very
complicated
but tensorflow does such a nice job that
you can spin different
setups up very easily and test them out
so you can test out these different
models to see how they work now
tensorflow has gone through two major
stages
we had the original tensorflow release
of 1.0
and then they came out with the 2.0
version
and the 2.0 addressed so many things out
there that the 1.0 really needed
so we start talking about tensorflow 1.0
versus 2.0
i guess you would need to know this for
a legacy programming job if you're
pulling apart somebody else's code the
first thing is that tensorflow 2.0
supports eager execution
by default it allows you to build your
models and run them instantly
and you can see here from tensorflow 1
to tensorflow 2
we have almost double the code to do the
same thing
so if i want to do with tf.session or
tensorflow session
as a session the session run you have
your variables your session run you have
your tables initializer
and then you do your model fit x train y
train and then your validation data your
x value y value
and your epics and your batch size all
that goes into the fit
and you can see here where that was all
just compressed to make it run easier
you can just create a model and do a fit
on it
and you only have like that last set of
code on there so it's automatic
that's what they mean by the eager so if
you see the first part you're like what
the heck is all the session thing going
on
that's tensorflow 1.0 and then when you
get into 2.0
it's just nice and clean if you remember
from the beginning i said cross
on our list up there and cross is the
high level
api in tensorflow 2.0 cross is the
official
high level api of tensorflow 2.0 it has
incorporated cross as
cross provides a number of model
building apis such as sequential
functional and subclassing so you can
choose the right level of abstraction
for your project
and we'll hopefully touch base a little
bit more on this sequential
being the most common form that is your
your layers are going from one side to
the other
so everything's going in a sequential
order functional
is where you can split the layers so you
might have your input coming on one side
it splits into two completely mod
different models
and then they come back together and one
of them might be doing
classification the other one might be
doing just linear regression kind of
stuff
or a neural basic reverse propagation
neural network
and then those all come together into
another layer which is your
neural network reverse propagation setup
subclassing is the most complicated as
you're building your own models and you
can subclass your own models into cross
so very powerful tools here this is all
the stuff that's been coming out
currently
in the tensorflow cross setup a third
big change we're going to look at
is it in tensorflow 1.0
in order to use tf layers as variables
you would have to write tf variable
block so you'd have to pre-define that
in tensorflow 2 you just add your layers
in under the sequential and it
automatically defines them as long as
they're flat layers
of course this changes a little bit as
the more complicated
tensor you have coming in but all of
it's very easy to do and that's what 2.0
does a really good job of
and here we have a little bit more on
the scope of this and you can see how
tensorflow 1 asks you to do
these different layers and values if you
look at the scope and the default name
you start looking at all the different
code in there to create the variable
scope
that's not even necessary in tensorf 2.0
so you'd have to do one before you do
do what you see the code in 2.0 in 2.0
you just create your model it's a
sequential model then you can add all
your layers in
you don't have to pre-create the
variable scope so if you ever see the
variable scope you know that came from
an
older version and then we have the last
two which is our api
cleanup and the autograph in the
api cleanup tensorflow 1 you could build
models using tf gans tf app
tf contrib tf flags etc in tensorflow 2
a lot of apis have been removed and this
is just
they just cleaned them up because people
weren't using them and they've
simplified them
and that's your tf app your tf flags
your tf logging are all gone
so there's those are three legacy
features that are not
in 2.0 and then we have our tf function
and autograph feature
in the old version tensorflow 1 0 the
python functions were limited
and could not be compiled or exported
re-imported
so you were continually having to redo
your code you couldn't very easily just
put a pointer to it and say hey let's
reuse this
in tensorflow 2 you can write a python
function using the tf function
to mark it for the jit compilation for
the python jit
so that tensorflow runs it as a single
graph
autograph feature of tf function helps
to write graph code using
natural python syntax now we just threw
in a new word in you graph
a graph is not a picture of a person
you'll hear graph x and some other
things graph
is what are all those lines that are
connecting different objects
so if you remember from before where we
had uh the different
layers going through sequentially each
one of those white lined arrows would be
a graph x
that's where that computation is taken
care of and that's what they're talking
about
and so if you had your own special code
or python way that you're sending that
information forward
you can now put your own function in
there instead of using whatever function
they're using
in neural networks this would be your
activation function although it could be
almost anything out there depending on
what you're doing
next let's go for hierarchy and
architecture
and then we'll cover three basic tools
in tensorflow before we roll up our
sleeves and dive into the example
so let's just take a quick look at
tensorflow toolkits in their hierarchy
at the high level we have our object
oriented api
so this is what you're working with you
have your tf cross you have your
estimators
this sits on top of your tf layers tf
losses tf metrics
so you have your reusable libraries for
model building
this is really where tensorflow shines
is between the cross
running your estimators and then being
able to swap in different layers
you can your losses your metrics all of
that is so built into tensorflow makes
it really easy to use
and then you can get down to your low
level tf api
you have extensive control over this you
can put your own formulas in there your
own procedures or models in there
you could have it split we talked about
that earlier so with the 2.0 you can now
have it split one direction we do a
linear regression model
and then go to the other where it does a
neural network
and maybe each neural network has a
different activation set on it
and then it comes together into another
layer which is
another neural network so you can build
these really complicated
models and at the low level you can put
in your own apis you can move that stuff
around
and most recently we have the tf code
can run on multiple
platforms and so you have your cpu
which is basically like on the computer
i'm running on i have
eight cores and 16 dedicated threads i
hear they now have one out there that
has over 100 cores
so you have your cpu running and then
you have your gpu which is your graphics
card
and most recently they also include the
tpu setup which is specifically for
tensorflow models neural network kind of
set up
so now you can export the tf code and it
can run on all kinds of different
platforms
for the most diverse setup out there
and moving on from the hierarchy to the
architecture
in the tensorflow 2.0 architecture
we have you can see on the left this is
usually where you start out with
and 80 percent of your time in data
science is spent
pre-processing data making sure it's
loaded correctly and everything looks
right
so the first level in tensorflow is
going to be your read and pre-processed
data your tf data feature columns
this is going to feed into your tf cross
or your pre-made estimators
and kind of you have your tensorflow hub
that sits on top of there so you can see
what's going on
uh once you have all that set up you
have your distribution strategy
where are you gonna run it you're gonna
be running it on just your regular cpu
are you gonna be running it uh with the
gpu added in
like i have a pretty high-end graphics
card so it actually grabs that gpu
processor and uses it
or do you have a specialized tpu set up
in there that you paid extra money for
it could be if you're in later on when
you're distributing the package
you might need to run this on some
really high processors because you're
processing at a server level for
let's say net you might be processing
this at a
distribute you're distributing it not
the distribution strategy
but you're distributing it into a server
where that server might be
analyzing thousands and thousands of
purchases done
every minute and so you need that higher
speed
to give them a to give them a
recommendation or a suggestion so they
can buy more stuff
off your website or maybe you're looking
for
a data fraud analysis working with the
banks you want to be able to run this
at a high speed so that when you have
hundreds of people
sending their transactions in it says
hey this doesn't look right someone's
scamming this person and probably has
their credit card so when we're talking
about
all those fun things we're talking about
saved model this is
we were talking about that earlier where
it used to be when you did one of these
models
it wouldn't truncate the float numbers
the same and so a model going from one
you build the model on your machine in
the office
and then you need to distribute it and
so we have our tensorflow serving cloud
on premium that's what i was talking
about if you're like a banking or
something like that
now they have tensorflow lite so you can
actually run a tensorflow on an
android or an ios or raspberry pi a
little breakout board there
in fact they just came out with a new
one that has a built-in there's just a
little mini tpu
with the camera on it so it can
pre-process a video so you can load your
tensorflow model onto that
um talking about an affordable way to
beta test
uh a new product you have the tensorflow
js which is for browser and node server
so you can get that out on the browser
for some simple computations that don't
require a lot of heavy lifting
but you want to distribute to a lot of
endpoints and now they also have other
language bindings so you can now
create your tensorflow backend save it
and have it accessed from c
java go c sharp rust r or from whatever
package you're working on
so we kind of have an overview of the
architecture and what's going
on behind the scenes and in this case
what's going on as far as distributing
it
let's go ahead and take a look at three
specific pieces
of tensorflow and those are going to be
constants variables and sessions
so very basic things you need to know
and understand when you're working with
the tensorflow
setup so constants in tensorflow
in tensorflow constants are created
using the function constant
in other words they're gonna stay static
the whole time whatever you're working
with
the syntax for constant value
d type nine shape equals none name
constant
verify shape equals false that's kind of
the syntax you're looking at and we'll
explore this
with our hands on a little more in depth
and you can see here we do z
equals tf.constant 5.2 name equals x
d type is a float that means that we're
never going to change that 5.2 it's
going to be a constant value
and then we have our variables in
tensorflow variables in tensorflow are
in memory buffers that store tensors
and so we can declare a two by three
tensor populated by ones
you could also do constants this way by
the way so you can create a
an array of ones for your constant in
here we have v equals tf.variables
and then in tensorflow you have tf.ones
and you have the shape which is two
three which is then going to create a
nice
two by three array that's filled with
ones and then of course you can go in
there and they're variables so you can
change them it's a tensor so you have
full control over that
and then you of course have sessions in
tensorflow
a session in tensorflow is used to run a
computational graph to evaluate the
nodes
and remember when we're talking a graph
or graph x we're talking about
all that information then goes through
all those arrows and whatever
computations they have that take it to
the next node
and you can see down here where we have
import tensorflow as tf
if we do x equals a t f dot constant of
10
we do y equals a tf constant of 2.0 or
20.0
and then you can do z equals tf.variable
and it's a tf dot add x comma y
and then once you have that set up in
there you go ahead and
knit your tf global variables
initializer
with tf session as session you can do a
session run and knit
and then you print the session run y
uh and so when you run this you're going
to end up with of course the
10 plus 20 is 30. and we'll be looking
at this a lot
more closely as we actually roll up our
sleeves and put some code together
so let's go ahead and take a look at
that and for my coding today i'm going
to go ahead and go through
anaconda and then i'll use specifically
the jupiter notebook on there
and of course this code is going to work
whatever platform you choose whether
you're in a notebook
the jupiter lab which is just a jupiter
notebook but with tabs for larger
projects
we're going to stick with jupiter
notebook pycharm
whatever it is you're going to use in
here you have your spider and your qt
console for different
programming environments the thing to
note
is kind of hard to see but i have my
main pi
36 right now when i was writing this
tensorflow
works in python version three six
if you have python version three seven
or three eight
you're probably going to get some errors
in there might be that they've already
updated and i don't know it now you have
an older version
but you want to make sure you're in a
python version 3 6 in your environment
and of course in anaconda i can easily
set that environment up
make sure you go ahead and and pip in
your
tensorflow or if you're in anaconda you
can do
a conda install tensorflow to make sure
it's in your package
so let's just go ahead and dive in and
bring that up
this will open up a nice browser window
i just love the fact i can zoom in and
zoom out
depending on what i'm working on making
it really easy to just um
demo for the right size go under new and
let's go ahead and create a new python
and once we're in our new python window
this is going to leave it untitled
let's go ahead and import import
tensorflow as tf at this point we'll go
ahead and just run it real quick
no errors yay no errors i
i do that whenever i do my imports
because i unbearably will have opened up
a new environment
and forgotten to install tensorflow into
that environment
or something along those lines so it's
always good to double check
and if we're going to double check that
we also it's also good to know
what version we're working with and we
can do that
simply by using the version command in
tensorflow
which you should know is is probably
intuitively the tf
dot underscore underscore version
underscore underscore
and you know it always confuses me
because sometimes you do tf.version for
one thing you do tf dot underscore
version underscore for another thing
this is a double underscore in
tensorflow for pulling your version out
and it's good to know what you're
working with we're going to be working
in
tensorflow version 2.1.0 and i did tell
you the
the um we were going to dig a little
deeper into our constants and you can do
an array of constants
and we'll just create this nice array a
equals tf.constant
and we're just going to put the ray
right in there 4361.
we can run this and now that is what a
is equal to and if we want to just
double check that
remember we're in jupiter notebook where
you can just put the letter a
and it knows that that's going to be
print otherwise you'd round you surround
it in print
and you can see it's a tf tensor it has
the shape the type and the and the array
on here it's a two by two array
and just like we can create a constant
we can go and create a variable
and this is also going to be a 2 by 2
array and if we go ahead and print the v
out we'll run that and sure enough
there's our tf
variable in here then we can
also let's just go back up here and add
this in here
i could create another tensor and we'll
make it a constant this time
and we're going to put that in over here
we'll have b
tf constant and if we go and print out
uh v and b i'm going to run that
and this is an interesting thing that
always that happens in here
you'll see right here when i print them
both out what happens it only prints the
last one unless you use print commands
so important to remember that in jupyter
notebooks we can easily fix that by go
ahead and print
and surround v with brackets and now we
can see with the two different variables
we have
we have the 3152 which is a variable
and this is just a flat constant so it
comes up as a tf tensor
shape 2 kind of two and that's
interesting to note
that this label is a tf.tensor and this
is a tf
variable so that's how it's looking in
the back end when you're talking about
the difference between a variable and a
constant
the other thing i want you to notice is
that in variable we capitalize the v
and with the constant we have a
lowercase c
little things like that can lose you
when you're programming and you're
trying to find out hey why doesn't this
work
so those are a couple little things to
note in here and
just like any other array in math we can
do like a
concatenate or concatenate the different
values here
and you can see we can take a b
concatenated
you just do a tf.concat values and
there's our a b
axes on one hopefully you're familiar
with axes and how that works when you're
dealing with matrixes
and if we go ahead and print this out
you'll see right here we end up with a
tensor so it's put it in as a constant
not as a variable
and you have your array 4 3 7 8 and six
one four five it's concatenated the two
together and again
i wanna highlight a couple things on
this our axis equals one
this means we're doing the columns um so
if you had a longer array
like right now we have an array that is
like you know has a shape
one whatever it is two comma two um
axes zero is going to be your first one
and axes one is going to be your second
one
and it translates as columns and rows if
we had a shape
let me just put the word shape here um
so you know what i'm talking about it's
very clear and this is i'll tell you
what i spent a lot of time
looking at these shapes and trying to
figure out which direction i'm going in
and whether to flip
it or whatever so you can get lost
in which way your matrix is going which
is column which is rows are you dealing
with the third axes
or the second axis axis one you know
zero one
two that's going to be our columns and
if you can do columns
then we also can do rows and that is
simply just changing the concatenate
we'll just grab this one here and copy
it we'll do the whole thing over
ctrl copy ctrl v
and changes from axes one to axis zero
and if we run that you'll see that now
we concatenate
by row as opposed to column and you have
four three six one seven eight four
seven so it just brings it right down
and turns it into rows versus columns
you can see the difference there your
output this really
you want to look at the output sometimes
just to make sure your eyes are looking
at it correctly
and it's in the format i find visually
looking at it is almost more important
than
understanding what's going on because
conceptually your mind just
just too many dimensions sometimes the
second thing i want you to notice is
this says a numpy array
so tensorflow is utilizing numpy as part
of their format
as far as python is concerned and so you
can treat you can treat this output like
a numpy array because it is just that
it's going to be a numpy array
another thing that comes up uh more than
you would think
is filling uh one of these with zeros or
ones and so you can see here we just
create a tensor tf.zeros
and we give it a shape we tell it what
kind of data type it is in this case
we're doing an integer
and then if we print out our tensor
again we're in jupiter so i can just
type out tensor
and i run this you can see i have a nice
array of
the shape three comma four of zeros one
of the things i want to highlight here
is
integer 32. if i go to the
tensorflow data types i want you to
notice how
we have float 16 float 32 float 64
complex if we scroll down you'll see the
integer down here 32
the reason for this is that we want to
control
how many bits are used in the precision
this is for
exporting it to another platform so what
would happen is i might run it on this
computer where python
goes does a float to indefinite however
long it wants to
and then we can take it but we want to
actually say hey we don't want that high
precision we want to be able to run this
on any computer
and so we need to control whether it's a
tf float 16
in this case we did an integer 32
we could also do this as a float so if i
run this as a float32
that means this has a 32 bit precision
you'll see zero point whatever
and then to go with zeros
we have ones if we're going from the
opposite side and so we can easily just
create a
tensorflow with ones and you might ask
yourself
why would i want zeros and ones and your
first thought might be to initiate a new
tensor
usually we initiate a lot of this stuff
with random numbers because it does a
better job
solving it if you start with a uniform
set of ones or zeros
you're dealing with a lot of bias so be
very careful about starting
a neural network for one of your rows or
something like that with ones and zeros
on the other hand i use this for masking
you can do a lot of work with masking
you can also have
it might be that one tensor row is
masked
you know zero is is false one is true or
whatever you want to do it
and so in that case you do want to use
the zeros and ones
and there are cases where you do want to
initialize it with all zeros or all ones
and then
swap in different numbers as the tensor
learns
so it's another form of control but in
general
you see zeros and ones you usually are
talking about a mask over another array
and just like in numpy you can also
do reshapes so if we take our remember
this is shaped three comma four
maybe we wanna swap that to four comma
three
and if we print this out you will see
let me just go and do that
ctrl v let me run that and you'll see
that the
the order of these is now switched
instead of four across now we have three
across and four down
and just for fun let's go back up here
where we did the ones
and i'm going to change the ones to
tf.random
uniform and we'll go ahead and just take
off well we'll go and leave that we're
going to run this
and you'll see now we have 0.0441
and this way you can actually see how
the reshape looks a lot different
uh 0.041.15.71
and then instead of having this one it
rolls down here to the 0.14
and this is what i was talking about
sometimes you feel
a lot of times you fill these with
random numbers and so this is
the random dot uniform is one of the
ways to do that now
i just talked a little bit about this
float 32
and all these data types one of the
things that comes up of course
is recasting your data
so if we have a d type float 32 we might
want to convert these to integers
because of the project we're working on
i know one of the projects i've worked
on
ended up wanting to do a lot of round
off so that it would take a dollar
amount or a float value and then have to
rent it off to a dollar amount so we
only wanted two decimal points
um in which case you have a lot of
different options you can multiply by a
hundred and then round it off or
whatever you want to do there's a lot of
or then converted to an integer was one
way to round it off
uh kind of a cheap and dirty trick
uh so we can take this and we can take
this same tensor and we'll go ahead and
create a
as an integer and so we're going to take
this tensor we're going to tf.cast it
and if we print
tensor and then we're going to go ahead
and print
our tensor let me just
do a quick copy and paste and when i'm
actually programming i usually type out
a lot of my stuff
just to double check it in doing a demo
copy and paste works fine but sometimes
be aware that copy and paste can copy
the wrong code over
personal choice depends on what i'm
working on and you can see here we took
a float 32 4.6 4.2 and so on
and it just converts it right down to a
integer value
sorry integer 32 set up and
remember we talked about a little bit
about reshape
as far as flipping it and i just did
four comma three on the reshape up here
and we talked about axis zero axis one
uh one of the things that is important
to be able to do
is to take one of these variables we'll
just take this last one tensor as
integer
and i want to go ahead and transpose it
and so i can do
we'll do a equals tf.transpose
and we'll do our tensor integer in there
and then if i print the a
out and we run this you'll see that's
the same array
but we've flipped it so that our columns
and rows are flipped
this is the same as reshaping so when
you transpose you're just doing a
reshape
what's nice about this is if you look at
the numbers the columns
when we went up here and we did the
reshape they kind of rolled down to the
next row
so you're not maintaining the structure
of your matrix
so when we do a reshape up here they're
similar but they're not quite the same
and you can actually go in here
and there's settings in the reshape that
would allow you to turn it into a
transform
so we come down here it's all done for
you and so there are so many times you
have to transpose
your digits that this is important to
know that you can just do that you can
flip your rows and columns rather
quickly here
and just like numpy you can also do
multiple your different math functions
we'll look at multiplication
and so we're going to take matrix
multiplication of tensors
we'll go ahead and create a as a
constant 5839
and we'll put in a vector v 4 comma 2.
and we could have done this where they
matched where this was a two by two
array
but instead we're going to do just a
two by one array and the code for that
is your tf.mat
mole so matrix multiplier
and we have a times v and if we go ahead
and run this up let's
make sure we print out our av on there
and if we go ahead and run this you'll
see that we end up
with 36 by 30. and if it's been a while
since you've seen the matrix math
this is 5 times 4 plus
8 times 2 3 times 4
plus 9 times 2 and that's where we get
the 36 and 30.
now i know we're covering a lot really
quickly as far as the basic
functionality so the matrix or your
matrix multiplier is a very commonly
used
back-end tool as far as computing
different models or linear regression
stuff like that
one of the things is to note is that
just like in numpy you have all of your
different math
so we have our tf math and if we go in
here we have
functions we have our cosines absolute
angle all of that's in here so all of
these
are available for you to use in the
tensorflow model
and if we go back to our example and
let's go ahead and pull
oh let's do some multiplication that's
always good we'll stick with our
av our constant a and our vector v
and we'll go ahead and do some bit wise
multiplication and we'll create an av
which is a times b let's go and print
that out
and you can see coming across here we
have the 4
2 and the five eight three nine and it
produces uh
twenty thirty two six eighteen
and that's pretty straightforward if you
look at you have four times
uh five is twenty four times eight is
32 that's where those numbers come from
we can also quickly create an identity
matrix which is basically
your main values on the diagonal being
ones and
zeros across the other side let's go
ahead and take a look and see what that
looks like and we can do let's do this
so we're going to get the shape this is
a simple way
very similar to your numpy you can do a
dot shape and it's going to return
a tuple in this case our rows and
columns and so we can do a quick
print we'll do rows
oops
and we'll do columns
and if we run this you can see we have
three rows
uh two columns and then if we go ahead
and create an identity
matrix
this whoops the script for that
got a wrong button there the script for
that looks like this
where we have the number of rows equals
rows the number of columns equals
columns and d type is a 32
and then if we go ahead and just print
out our identity
you can see we have a nice identity
column with our ones going across here
now clearly we're not going to go
through every math module
available but we do want to start
looking at this
as a prediction model and seeing how it
functions
so we're going to move on to a more of a
direct setup we can actually see the
full tensorflow in use
for that let's go back and create a
new setup
and we'll go in here new python 3 module
there we go bring this out so it takes
up the whole window because i like to do
that
hopefully you made it through that first
part and you have a basic understanding
of tensorflow as far as being
a series of numpy arrays you've got your
math equations and different things that
go into them
we're going to start building a full
setup as far as the numpy so you can see
how kara sits on top of it and the
different aspects of how it works
the first thing we want to do is we're
going to go ahead and do a lot of
imports
date times warning scipy scipy
is your math so
the back end scientific math warnings
because
whenever we do a lot of this you have
older versions
newer versions and so sometimes when you
get warnings you want to go ahead and
just suppress them
we'll talk about that if it comes up on
this particular setup
and of course date time pandas again
is your data frame think rows and
columns we import it as pd
numpy is your numbers array which of
course tensorflow is integrated heavily
with
seaborn for our graphics and the seaborn
as sns is going to be set on top of our
map plot library which we import as
mpl and then of course we're going to
import our matplot library pi plot as
plt and right off the bat we're going to
set some graphic colors
patch force edge color equals true
the style we're going to use the 538
style
you can look this all up there's when
you get into matplot library into
seaborne
there are so many options in here it's
just kind of nice to make it look pretty
when we start the um
when we start up that way we don't have
to think about it later on
uh and then we're going to take we have
our mplrc we're going to put a patch ed
color
dim gray line width again this is all
part of our graphics here
in our setup we'll go ahead and do an
interactive shell
node interactivity equals last
expression
here we are pd for pandas options
display max columns
so we don't want to display more than
50. and then our matplot library is
going to be inline
this is a jupiter notebook thing the
matplot library in line
and then warnings we're going to filter
our warnings and we're just going to
ignore warnings
that way when they come up we don't have
to worry about them not really what you
want to do when you're working on
a major project you want to make sure
you know those warnings and then
filter them out and ignore them later on
and if we run this it's just going to be
loading all that
into the background so that's a little
back end kind of stuff
then we want to go ahead and do is we
want to go ahead and import
our specific packages that we're going
to be working with which is under cross
now remember cross kind of sits on
tensorflow so when we're importing cross
and the sequential model we are in
effect importing
tensorflow underneath of it we just
brought in the math probably should have
put that up above
and then we have our cross models we're
going to import sequential
now if you remember from our
slide there was three different options
let me just flip back over there so we
can have a quick
recall on that and so in cross
we have sequential functional and
subclassing
so remember those three different setups
in here we talked about earlier
and if you remember from here we have a
sequential where it's going
one tensorflow layer at a time you go
kind of like think of it as going from
left to right or top to bottom or
whatever direction it's going in
but it goes in one direction all the
time where functional
can have a very complicated graph of
directions you can have the data split
into two separate
tensors and then it comes back together
into another tensor
all those kinds of things and then
subclassing is really the really
complicated one
where now you're adding your own
subclasses into the
tensor to do external computations right
in the middle of like a huge flow of
data
but we're going to stick with sequential
it's not a big jump to go from
sequential to functional
but we're running a sequential
tensorflow and that's what this first
import is here we want to bring in our
sequential and then we have our layers
and let's talk a little bit about these
layers this is where
cross and tensorflow really are
happening this is what makes them so
nice to work with is all these layers
are pre-built
so from cross we have layers import
dense
from cross layers import lstm
when we talk about these layers
cross has so many built-in layers you
can do your own layers
the dense layer is your standard neural
network
by default it uses relu for its
activation
and then the lstm is a long short term
memory layer since we're going to be
looking probably at sequential data
we want to go ahead and do the lstm and
if we go
into cross and we look at their layers
this is across website
you can see as we scroll down for the
cross layers that are built in
we can get down here and we can look at
let's see here we have our layer
activation our base layers
activation layer weight layer waste
there's a lot of stuff in here
we had the relu which is the basic
activation that was listed
up here for layer activations you can
change those
and here we have our core layers and our
dense layers we have an input layer a
dense layer
and then we've added a more customized
one with the long-term short-term memory
layer and of course you can even do your
own custom layers
in cross there's a whole functionality
in there if you're doing your own thing
what's really nice about this is it's
all built in even the
convolutional layers this is for
processing graphics
there's a lot of cool things in here you
can do this is white cross is
so popular it's open source and you have
all these tools right at your fingertips
so from cross we're just going to import
a couple layers the dense layer
and the long short term memory layer and
then of course from
sk learn our scikit we want to go ahead
and do our min max scalar standard
scalar for pre
editing our data and then metrics just
so we can take a look at the errors and
compute those
let me go ahead and run this and that
just loads it up we're not expecting
anything
from the output and our file coming in
is going to be air quality.csv
let's go ahead and take a quick look at
that this is in openoffice it's just a
standard
you know you might do excel whatever
you're using for your spreadsheet
and you can see here we have a number of
columns
a number of rows it actually goes down
to like 8 000
the first thing we want to notice is
that the first row
is kind of just a random number put in
going down probably not something we're
going to work with
the second row is bendung
i'm guessing that's a reference for the
profile if we scroll to the bottom which
i'm not going to do because it takes
forever to get back up
they're all the same the same thing with
the status the status is the same
we have a date so we have a sequential
order
here here is the jam which i'm going to
guess is the time stamp on there
so we have a date and time we have our
o3
co no2 reading so2 no co2
voc and then some other numbers here pm1
pm 2.5 pm 4 pm 10
10 without actually looking through the
data
i mean some of the second guess is like
temperature humidity i'm not sure what
the pms are
but we have a whole slew of data here so
we're looking at air quality
as far as an area in a region and what's
going on
with our date time stamps on there and
so code wise we're going to read this
into a panda's data frame so our data
frame
df is a nice abbreviation commonly used
for data frames
equals pd.read csv and then our the path
to it just happens to be on my d
drive separated by spaces and so if we
go ahead and run this
we'll print out the head of our data and
again this looks very similar to what we
were just looking at
being in jupiter i can take this and go
the other way
make it real small so you can see all
the columns going across and we get a
full view of
it or we can bring it back up in size
that's pretty small on there overshot
but you can see it's the same data we
were just looking at we're looking at
the number we're looking at the profile
which is the bandung
the date we have a time stamp
our o3 count co and so forth on here
and this is just your basic pandas
printing out the top five rows
we could easily have done uh three rows
uh five rows ten whatever you wanna put
in there by default that's
five for pandas now i talk about this
all the time so i know i've already said
it at least once or twice during this
video
most of our work is in pre-formatting
data what are we looking at how do we
bring it together
so we want to go ahead and start with
our date time
it's come in in two columns we have our
date here
and we have our time and we want to go
ahead and combine that
and then we have this is just a simple
script in there that says combined
datetime that's our formula we're
building
our we're going to submit our pandas
data frame
and the tab name let me go ahead and do
this
that's all of our information that we
want to go ahead and create
and then goes for i in range df shape 0.
so we're going to go through the whole
setup and we're going to list
tab append df location i and
here is our date going in there
and then return the numpy array list tab
d types date time 64.
that's all we're doing we're just
switching this to a date time stamp and
if we go ahead
and do df date time equals combined date
time
and then i always like to uh print we'll
do df head
just to see what that looks like and so
when we come out of this
we now have our setup on here and of
course it's added it on to the far right
here's our date time
you can see the format's changed so
there's our
we've added in the date time column and
we've brought the date over
and we've taken this format here and
it's an actual
variable with a 0 0 0 on here
well that doesn't look good so we need
to also include the time part of this
we want to convert it into hourly data
so let's go ahead and do that to do that
to finish combining our date time let's
go ahead and create a
a little script here to combine the time
in there
same thing we just did we're just
creating a numpy array returning a numpy
array
and cr forcing this into a date time
format
and we can actually spend hours just
going through
these conversions how do you pull it
from the
pandas data frame how do you set it up
so i'm kind of skipping through it a
little fast because i want to stay
focused on tensorflow and cross
keep in mind this is like 80 of your
coding when you're doing a lot of this
stuff
is going to be reformatting these things
resetting them back up
so that it looks right on here and you
know it just takes time to get through
all that but that is usually what the
companies are paying you for that's what
the
big bucks are for
and we want to go ahead and a couple
things going on here is we're going to
go ahead and do our date time we're
going to reorganize some of our setup in
here
convert into hourly data we just put a
pause in there
now remember we can select from df are
different columns we're going to be
working with and you're going to see
that we actually dropped
a couple of the columns those ones i
showed you earlier they're just
repetitive data
so there's nothing in there that
exciting and then we want to go ahead
and we'll create a
second data frame here let me just get
rid of the df head
and df2 is we're going to group by date
time and we're looking at the mean value
and then we'll print that out so you can
see we're talking about
we have now reorganized this so we put
in date time
03 co so now this is in the same order
as it was before and you'll see the date
time
now has our 0 0
same date 1 2 3 and so on so let's group
the data together
so there's a lot more manageable and in
the format we want
and in the right sequential order and if
we go back to
there we go our air quality you can see
right here we're looking at
these columns going across we really
don't need since we're going to create
our own
date time column we can get rid of those
these are the different columns of
information we want
and that should reflect right here in
the columns we picked
coming across so this is all the same
columns on there that's all we've done
is reformatted our data
grouped it together by date and then you
can see the different data coming out
set up on there and then as a data
scientist
first thing i want to do is get a
description what am i looking at
uh and so we can go ahead and do the df2
describe
and this gives us our you know describe
gives us our basic
data analytics information we might be
looking for like what is the mean
standard deviation uh minimum amount
maximum amount we have our first quarter
second quarter and third quarter
um numbers also in there so you can get
a quick look at a glance describing the
data or descriptive analysis
and even though we have our quantile
information in here we're going to dig a
little deeper into that
we're going to calculate the quantile
for each variable we're going to look at
a number of things for each variable
and we'll see right here q1 we can
simply do the quantile 0.25 percent
which should match um our 25 percent up
here
and we're going to be looking at the min
the max and we're just going to do this
is basically we're
breaking this down for each uh
different variable in there one of the
things that's kind of
fun to do we're going to look at that in
just a second let me get
put the next piece of code in here clean
out some of our
um we're going to drop a couple thing
our last rows and first row because
those have
usually have a lot of null values and
the first row is just our titles uh so
that's important it's important to drop
those rows in here
and so this right here as we look at our
different quantiles again it's it's the
same
you know we're still looking at the 25
quantile
here we're going to do a little bit more
with this
so now that we've cleared off our first
and last rows we're going to go ahead
and go through all of our columns and
this way we can look at each
column individually and so we'll just
create a q1
q3 min max min iqr max iqr
and calculate the quantile of i of df2
we're basically doing the math that they
did up here but we're splitting it apart
that's all this is and this happens a
lot because you might want to look at
individual
if this was my own project i would
probably spend days and days
going through what these different
values mean
one of the biggest data science
things we can look at that's important
uh use your use your common sense you
know if you're looking at this data and
it doesn't make sense and you go back in
there and you're like wait a minute what
the heck did i just do
at that point you probably should go
back and double check what you have
going on
now we're looking at this and you can
see right here here's our attribute for
our o3
so we've broken it down uh we have our
q1
5.88 q3 10.37 if we go back up here
here's our five eight we've rounded it
off
10.37 is in there
so we've basically done the same math
just split it up we have our minimum and
our max iqr
and that's computed let's see where is
it here we go
uh q1 minus 1.5 times iqr
and the iqr is your q3 minus q1 so
that's the difference between our two
different quarters
and this is all data science
as far as the hard math we're really not
we're actually trying to focus on cross
and tensorflow
you still got to go through all this
stuff i told you 80
of your programming is going through and
understanding
what the heck happened here
what's going on what does this data mean
and so
when we're looking in that we're going
to go ahead and say hey
we've computed these numbers and the
reason we've computed these numbers
is if you take the minimum value and
it's less than your
minimum iqr
that means something's going wrong there
and it usually in this case is going to
show us an outlier
so we want to go ahead and find the
minimum value if it's less than the min
minimum iqr it's an outlier and if the
max value is greater than the
max iqr we have an outlier and that's
all this is doing
low outliers found minimum value high
outliers found
really important actually outliers are
almost everything in data sometimes
sometimes you do this project
just to find the outliers because you
want to know uh
crime detection what are we looking for
we're looking for the outliers what
doesn't fit a normal business deal
and then we'll go ahead and throw in
just threw in a lot of code oh my
goodness
uh so we have if your max is greater
than iqr
print outlier is found what we want to
do is we want to start cleaning up these
outliers
and so we want to convert we'll do
create a convert
nand x max iqr equals max
uh underscore iqr min iqr equals mini qr
so this is just saying this is the data
we're going to send that's all that is
in
python and if x is greater than the max
iqr
and x is less than the min iqr x equals
null we're going to set it to null why
because we want to clear
these outliers out of the data now again
if you're doing fraud detection you
would do the opposite
you would be cleaning everything else
that's not in that
series so that you can look at just the
outlier uh and then we're going to
convert the
nand hum again we have x max iqr is 100
percent
min iqr is men iqr if x is greater than
max iqr
and x is less than min iqr again we're
going to return
null value otherwise it's going to
remain the same value
x x equals x and you can see
as we go through the code if i equals
our hum then we go ahead and do this
that's a column specific to humidity
that's your
hum column uh then we're going to go
ahead and convert
do the run a map on there and convert
the non
e2m uh you can see here it's this is
just cleanup
uh we run we found out that humidity
probably has some weird values in it
we have our outliers that's all this
is and so when we go ahead and finish
this and we take a look at our outliers
and we run this code here
we have a low outlier 2.04 we have a
high outlier
99.06 outliers have been
interpolated
that means we've given them a new value
chances are
these days when you're looking at
something like these sensors coming in
they probably have a failed sensor in
there something went wrong
that's the kind of thing that you really
don't want to do your data analysis on
so that's what we're doing is we're
pulling that out and then
converting it over and setting it up
method linear
so we interpolate let the linears it's
going to fill that data
in based on a linear regression model of
similar data
same thing with this up here with the um
df2y interpolate
that's what we're doing again this is
all data prep
we're not actually talking about
tensorflow we're just trying to get all
our data
set up correctly so that when we run it
it's not going to cause problems or have
a huge bias
so we've dealt with outliers
specifically in humidity
and again this is one of these things
where when we start running
um we ran through this
you can see down here that we have our
outliers
found high low outliers
migrated them in we also know there's
other issues going on with this data
how do we know that some of it's just
looking at the data playing with it
until you start understanding what's
going on
let's take the temp value and we're
going to go ahead and
use a logarithmic function on the temp
value
and it's interesting because it's like
how do you how do you heck do you even
know to use logarithmic
on the temp value that's domain specific
we're talking about being an expert in
air care i'm not an expert in air care
um you know it's not what i go look at i
don't look at air care data in fact this
is probably the first air care data set
up i've looked at but the experts come
in there and they come to you and say
hey in data science
this is a exponentially very variable on
here so we need to go ahead and do
transform it and use a logarithmic scale
on that
so at that point that would be coming
from your
data here we go data science programmer
overview does a lot of stuff connecting
the database and connecting in with the
experts
data analytics a lot of times you're
talking about somebody who
is a data analysis might be all the way
usually a phd level
data science programming level
interfaces database manager that's going
to be the person who's your admin
working on it
so when we're looking at this we're
looking at something they've sent to me
and they said hey
domain air care this needs to be this is
a skew because the data just goes up
exponentially and affects everything
else
and we'll go ahead and take that data
let me just go ahead and run this
just for another quick look at it we
have our
uh we'll do a distribution df we'll
create another data frame from the temp
values and then from a data set from the
log temp so we can put them side by side
and we'll just go ahead and do a quick
histogram and this is kind of nice plot
of figure figure size here's our plt
from matplot library
and then we'll just do a distribution
underscore df
there's our data frames this is nice
because it just integrates the histogram
right into pandas
love pandas and this is a chart you
would send back to your data analysis
and say hey is this what you wanted this
is how the data is converting on here
as a data science scientist the first
thing i note is we've gone from a 10
20 30 scales at 2.5 3.0 3.5 scale
and the data itself has kind of been
adjusted a little bit based on some kind
of a skew on there
so let's jump into we're getting a
little closer to actually doing our
cross on here we'll go ahead and split
our data
up and this of course is any good data
scientists
you want to have a training set and a
test set
and we'll go ahead and do the train size
we're going to use 0.75 percent of the
data
make sure it's an integer we don't want
to take a slice as a float value
give you a nice error and we'll have our
train size of 75
and the test size is going to be um of
course the
train size minus the length of the data
set and then we can simply do train
comma test
here's our data set which is going to be
the train size the test size
and then if we go and print this let me
just go ahead and run this we can see
how these values
split it's a nice split of 1298 and then
433 points of value
they're going to be for our setup on
here
and if you remember we're specifically
looking at the data set where did we
create that data set from
that was from up here that's what we
called the logarithmic
value of the temp that's where the data
set came from
so we're looking at just that column
with this train size and the test
with the train and test data set here
and let's go ahead and do uh
convert an array of values into a data
set matrix
we're going to create a little setup in
here we create our data set our data
set's going to come in
we're going to do a look back of one so
we're going to look back one piece of
data going backward
and we have our data x and our data y
for i and range length of data set look
back -1
this is creating let me just go ahead
and run this actually the best way to do
this
is to go ahead and create this data and
take a look at the shape of it
uh let me go ahead and just put that
code in here so we're gonna do a look
back one here's our train x our train y
and it's going to be adding the data on
there and then when we come up here
and we take a look at the shape there we
go
and we run this piece of code here we
look at the shape on this and we have a
new slightly different change on here
but we have a shape of
x 1296 comma 1 shape of y
train y test x text y
and so what we're looking at is that
the x comes in and we're only having a
single value at
out uh we want to predict what the next
one is
that's what this little piece of code is
here for what are we looking for well we
want to look back one
that's the um what we're going to train
the data with is yesterday's data
yesterday says hey the
humidity was at 97 percent what should
today's humidity be at if it's 97
yesterday is it going to go up or is it
going to go down today
if 97 does it go up to 100 what's going
on there
and so our we're looking forward to the
next piece of data which says hey
tomorrow's is going to you know today's
humidity is this
this is what tomorrow's humidity is
going to be that's all that is
all that is is stacking our data so that
our
y is basically x plus 1
or x could be y minus 1.
and then a couple things to note is our
x
data we're only dealing with the one
column but you
need to have it in a shape that has it
by the columns so you have the two
different numbers
and since we're doing just a single
point of data
we have and you'll see with the train y
we don't need to have the extra shape on
here now this is going to run into a
problem
and the reason is is that we have what
they call a time
step and the time step is that long-term
short-term memory layer
so we're going to add another reshape on
here let me just go down here and put it
into the next cell
and so we want to reshape the input
array in the form of sample time step
features we're only looking at one
feature
and i mean this is one of those things
when you're playing with this you're
like why am i getting an error
in the numpy array why is this giving me
something weird going on
uh so we're gonna do is we're gonna add
one more uh level on here instead of
being
one we want to go one more
and when they put the code together in
the back you can see we
kept the same shape the 1299 we added
the one dimension
and then we have our train x shape one
and this could have
depends again on how far back in the
long short term memory you want to go
that is what that piece of code is for
and that reshape is
and you can see the new shape is now one
uh
1299 111 versus the 1299
one and then the other part of the shape
432 1 1
again this is our tr our x in and of
course our test x
and then our y is just a single column
because we're just doing
one output that we're looking for so now
we've done our 80 percent
um you know that's all the the writing
all the code reformatting our data
um bringing it in now we want to go
ahead and do the fun part which is we're
going to go ahead and create and fit
the lstm neural network and if we're
going to do that the first thing we need
is we're going to need to go ahead and
create a model
and we'll do this sequential model and
if you remember sequential means it just
goes in order
that means we have if you have two
layers the layers go from layer one to
layer two or layer zero to layer one
this is different than functional
functional allows you to split the data
and run two completely separate models
and then bring them back together we're
doing just sequential on here
and then we decided to do the long short
term
memory uh and we have our input shape
which it comes in again this is what all
this switching was we could have easily
made this
one two three or four going back as far
as the
end number on there we just stuck to
going back one
and it's always a good idea when you get
to this point where the heck
is this model coming from what kind of
models do we have available
and there's let me go and put the next
model in there
because we're going to do two models and
the next model is going to go ahead and
we're going to do dent so we have model
equal sequential
and then we're going to add the lstm
model and then we're going to add a
dense model and if you remember from the
very top of our code
where we did the imports oops there we
go our cross
this is it right here here's our
importing a dense model and here's our
importing
an lstm now just about
every tensorflow model uses dents
your dense model is your basic forward
propagation
reverse propagation error or it does
reverse propagation to program the model
so any of your neural networks you've
already looked at that
luxon says here's the error and sends
the error backwards that's what this
is the long short term memory is a
little different
the real question that we want to look
at right now is where
do you find these models what kind of
models do you have available and
so for that let's go to the cross
website
which is the cross dot io if you go
under api
layers and i always have to do a search
just search for
cross api layers it'll open up and you
can see we have
um your base layers right here class
trainable weights all kinds of stuff
like there your activation
so a lot of your layers you can switch
how it activates uh relu which is like
your smaller
arrays or if you're doing convolutional
neural networks the convolution usually
uses a relu
your sigmoid all the way up to softmax
soft plus all these different choices as
far as how those
are set up and what we want to do is we
want to go ahead
and if you scroll down here you'll see
your core layers and here is your dense
layer
so you have an input object your dense
layer your activation layer embedding
layer
this is your your kind of your one set
up on there that's most common
uh convolutional neural networks or
convolutional layers these are like for
doing
uh image categorizing uh so trying to
find objects in a picture that kind of
thing
we have pooling layers so as you have
the layers come together
usually bring them down into a single
layer
although you can still do like global
max pulling 3d and there is just
i mean this list just goes on and on
there's all kinds of different things
hidden in here
as far as what you can do and it changes
you know you go in here and you just
have to do a search for what you're
looking for
and figure out what's going to work best
for you
as far as which project you're working
on uh long
short term memory is a big one because
this is when we start talking about
text uh what if someone says the
what comes after the uh the cat in the
hat
a little kid's book there it starts
programming it and so you really want to
know
not only what's going on but it's going
to be something that has a history the
history behind it
tells you what the next one coming up is
now
once we've built all our different you
know we built our
model we've added our different layers
we went in there
play with it remember if you're in
functional you can actually link these
layers together and they branch out and
come back together
if you do a the sub
set up then you can create your own
different model you can embed a model in
there that might become
linear regression you can embed a linear
regression model
as part of your functional split and
then have that come back together with
other things
so we're going to go ahead and compile
your model this brings everything
together we're going to put in what the
loss is which we'll use the mean squared
error
and we'll go ahead and use the atom
optimizer clearly there's a lot of
choices on here depending on what you're
doing
and just like any of these different
prediction models
if you've been doing any uh scikit from
python
uh you'll recognize that we have to then
fit the model
so what are we doing in here we're going
to send in our train x our train y
um we're going to decide how many epochs
we're going to run it through
500 is probably a lot for this i'm
guessing it'd probably be about 200 or
300 probably do just fine
our batch size so how many different uh
when you
process it this is the math behind it if
you're
in data analytics you might try know
what this number is as a data scientist
where i haven't had the phd level math
that says this is why you want to use
this particular batch size you kind of
play with this number a little bit
you can dig deeper into the math see how
it affects the results
depending on what you're doing and
there's a number of other settings on
here
we did verbose 2. i'd have to actually
look that up to tell you what verbose
means
i think that's actually the default on
there if i remember correctly
there's a lot of different settings when
you go to fit it the big ones are your
epic and your batch size
those are what we're looking for and so
we're going to go ahead and run this
and this is going to take a few minutes
to run because it's going through
500 times through all the data
so if you have a huge data set this is
the point
where you're kind of wondering oh my
gosh is this going to finish tomorrow
if i'm running this on a single machine
and i have a tera
terabyte of data going into it
if this is my personal computer and i'm
running a terabyte of data into this
you know this is running rather quickly
through all 500 iterations
uh but yeah a terabyte of data we're
talking something closer to
days week um you know even with a
a 3.5 gigahertz machine and in
eight cores it's still going to take a
long time to go through a full terabyte
of data
and then we want to start looking at
putting it into some other framework
like spark or something that will print
the process on there more across
multiple um processors and multiple
computers
and if we scroll all the way down to the
bottom you're going to see here's our
square mean error of 0.0088
if we scroll way up you'll see it kind
of oscillates between 0.088 and 0.8089
it's right around 2 to 250 where you
start seeing that oscillation where it's
really not going anywhere
so we really didn't need to go through a
full 500 epics
you know if you're retraining this stuff
over and over again it's kind of good to
know where that
error zone is so you don't have to do
all the extra processing
of course if you're going to build a
model we want to go ahead and run a
prediction on it
so let's go ahead and make our
prediction remember we have our training
test set and our test set or the
we have the train x and the train y
for training it or train predict and
then we have our test
x and our test y going in there
so we can test to see how good it did
and we come in here we have you'll see
right here we go ahead and do our train
predict
equals model predict train x
and test predict model predict test x
why would we want to run the prediction
on train x well it's not a hundred
percent on its prediction
we know it has a certain amount of error
and we want to compare
the error we have on what we programmed
it with with the error we get when we
run it on new data that's never seen the
model's never seen before
and one of the things we can do we go
ahead and invert the predictions
this helps us level it off a little bit
more
get rid of some of our bias we have
train predict equals and np
exponential m1 the train predict and
then train y
equals the exponential m1 for train y
and then we do the again that with train
test predict and test
why again reformatting the data so that
we can
it all matches and then we want to go
ahead and calculate the root mean square
error
so we have our train score which is your
math square root times the mean square
root error train
y and train predict and again we're just
um this is just
feeding the data through so we can
compare it and the same thing with the
test
and let's take a look at that because
really the code makes sense if you're
going through it line by line you can
see what we're doing
but the answer really helps to zoom in
uh so we have a
train score which is 2.40
of our root mean square error and we
have a test score of 3.16 of the root
mean square error
if these were reversed if our test score
is better than our training score
then we've over trained something's
really wrong at that point you got to go
back and figure out what you did wrong
because you should never have a better
result on your test data than you do
when you're training data
and that's why we put them both through
that's why we look at the error for both
the training and the testing
when you're going out and quoting you're
publishing this and you're saying hey
how good is my model
it's the test score that you're showing
people this is what it did on my test
data that the model had never seen
before
this is how good my model is and a lot
of times you actually want to put
together like a little
formal code where we actually want to
print that out
and if we print that out you can see
down here
test prediction standard deviation of
data set 3.16 is less than 4.40
i'd have to go back and we're up here
if you remember we did the square means
error this is standard deviation that's
why these numbers are different
it's saying the same thing that we just
talked about
3.16 is less than 4.40 model is good
enough we're saying hey this is this
model is valid we have a valid model
here so we can go ahead and go with that
uh and along with putting a formal print
out of there
we want to go ahead and plot what's
going on
and this we just want to pretty graft
here so that people can see what's going
on
when i walk into a meeting and i'm
dealing with a number of people
they really don't want these numbers
they don't want to say hey what's
i mean standard deviation unless you
know what statistics are
you might be dealing with a number of
different departments head of cells
might not work with standard deviation
or have any idea what that really means
number wise
and so at this point we really want to
put it in a graph so we have something
to display
and with displaying you remember that
we're looking at uh the data
today going into it and what's going to
happen tomorrow
so let's take a quick look at this we're
going to go ahead and shift the train
predictions for plotting
we have our train predict plot uh np
empty like data set uh train predict
plot
uh set it up with uh null values
yeah you know it's just kind of it's
kind of a weird thing where
we're creating the um the data groups as
we like them
and then putting the data in there is
what's going on here
so we have our train predict plot uh
which is going to be our look back
our length plus look back
we're just is going to equal train train
predict
so we're creating this basically we're
taking this and we're dumping the train
predict into it
so now we have our nice train predict
plot
and then we have the shift test
predictions for the plotting we're going
to continue more of that
oops looks like i put it in here double
no it's just uh yeah they put it in here
double
um didn't mean to do that we really only
need to do it once
oh here we go um this is where the
problem was is because
this is the test predict so we have our
training prediction
we're doing the shift on here and then
the test predict
we're going to look at that same thing
we're just creating those two
data sets uh test predict plot
length prediction set up on there and
then we're going to go through the
plotting the original data set and the
predictions
so we have a time axis always nice to
have your time set on there
set that to the time array time axes lap
all this is setting up the time variable
for the bottom
and then we have a lot of stuff going on
here as far as setting up
our figure let's go ahead and run that
and then we'll break it down
we have on here uh our main plot
we have two different plots going on
here the ispu going up and the data and
the ispu here
with all these different settings on it
and so we look at this we have our ax1
that's the main plot i mean our ax
that's the main plot and we have our ax1
which is the secondary plot over here
so we're doing a figure plt or
plt.figure
and we're going to dump those two graphs
on there and so we take
and if you go through the code piece by
piece
which we're not going to do we're going
to do the
the data set here
exponential reverse exponential so it
looks correctly
we're going to label it the original
data set
we're going to plot the train predict
plot
that's what we just created we're going
to make that orange
and we'll label it train prediction uh
test predicts plot we're going to make
that red and label it test prediction
and so forth set our ticks up this
actually just put ticks
time axes gets its ticks the little
little marks they're going along the
axes that kind of thing
and let's take a look and see what these
graphs look like
and these are just kind of fun you know
when you show up into a meeting and this
is the final output you say hey this is
what we're looking at
here's our original data in blue here's
our
training prediction you can see that it
trains pretty close to what the data is
up there
i would also probably put a like a
little
little time stamp and do just right
before and right after
where we go from train to test
prediction
and you can see with the test prediction
the data comes in in red
and then you can also see what the
original data set look like behind it
and how it differs
and then we can just isolate that here
on the right that's all this
is um is just the test prediction on the
right
uh and it's you know there's you'll see
what the original data set there's a lot
of peaks were missing and a lot of lows
were missing
but as far as the actual test prediction
it's pretty
does pretty good it's pretty right on
you can get a good idea what to expect
for your ispu
and so from this we would probably
publish it and say hey this is
um what you expect and this is our area
of this is a range of
error that's the kind of thing i put out
on a daily basis maybe we predict the
cells are going to be this or maybe
weekly
so you kind of get a nice you kind of
flatten the
data coming out and you say hey this is
what we're looking at the big
takeaway from this is that we're working
with
let me go back up here oops oh too far
there we go
is this model here this is what this is
all about we work through all of those
pieces
um all the tensorflows and that is to
build
this sequential model and we're only
putting in the two layers
this can get pretty complicated if you
get too complicated it never
it never verges into a usable model
so if you have like 30 different layers
in here there's a good chance you might
crash it kind of thing
so don't go too haywire on that and that
you kind of learn as you go
again it's domain knowledge and also
starting to understand all these
different layers and what they mean
the data analytics behind those layers
is something that your data analysis uh
professional would come in
and say this is what we want to try but
i tell you as a data scientist
um a lot of these basic setups are
common
and i don't know how many times uh
working with somebody and they're like
oh my gosh if i only did a
tangent h instead of a relu activation
i worked for two weeks to figure that
out well as a data science i can
run it through the model in you know
five minutes instead of spending two
weeks doing the the math behind it
so that's one of the advantages of data
scientist is we do it from programming
side
and data analytics is going to look for
it how does it work in math
and this is really the core right here
of
tensorflow and cross is being able to
build your data model quickly and
efficiently
and of course uh with any data science
putting out a pretty graph so that your
shareholders
again we want to take and reduce
the information down to something people
can look at and say oh
that's what's going on they can see
stuff what's going on as far as the
dates and the change in the ispu
welcome to karass tutorial my name is
richard kirschner
with the simply learn team that's
www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead so we're going
to dive right into what is cross
we'll also go all the way through this
into a couple of tutorials because
that's where you really learn a lot is
when you roll up your sleeves so we talk
about what is
cross cross is a high level deep
learning api
written in python for easy implement
implementation
of neural networks it uses deep learning
frameworks such as tensorflow pi
torch etc is back in to make computation
faster and this is really nice because
as a programmer there is so much stuff
out there and it's evolving so fast
it can get confusing and having some
kind of high level order in there we can
actually view it
and easily program these different
neural networks
is really powerful it's really powerful
to
have something out really quick and also
be able to start testing your models and
seeing where you're going
so crossworks by using complex deep
learning frameworks such as tensorflow
pytorch
ml played etc as a backend for fast
computation
while providing a user user-friendly and
easy to learn
front-end and you can see here we have
the cross api
specifications and under that you'd have
like tf cross for tensorflow
thano cross and so on and then you have
your tensorflow workflow that this is
all sitting on top of
and this is like i said it organizes
everything the heavy lifting is still
done by
tensorflow or whatever you know
underlying package you put in there
and this is really nice because you
don't have to
dig as deeply into the heavy end stuff
while still having a very robust package
you can get up and running rather
quickly
and it doesn't distract from the
processing time because all the heavy
lifting is done by packages like
tensorflow
this is the organization on top of it so
the working principle of cross
the working principle of keras is cross
uses computational graphs to express
and evaluate mathematical expressions
you can see here we put in blue they
have the expression
expressing complex problems as a
combination of simple mathematical
operators
uh where we have like the percentage or
in this case in python that's usually
your
left your remainder or multiplication
you might have the operator of x to the
power of
0.3 and it uses useful for calculating
derivatives by using
back propagation so if we're doing with
neural networks we send the error back
up to figure out how to change it this
makes it really easy to do that without
really having not banging your head and
having to handwrite everything
it's easier to implement distributed
computation and for solving complex
problems uh specify input and outputs
and make sure all nodes are connected
and so this is really nice as you come
in through is that as your layers are
going in there
you can get some very complicated
different setups nowadays which we'll
look at in just a second
and this just makes it really easy to
start spinning this stuff
up and trying out the different models
so we look across
models across model we have a sequential
model
sequential model is a linear stack of
layers where the previous layer leads
into the next layer
and this if you've done anything else
even like the sk learn with their neural
networks and propagation and any of
these setups
this should look familiar you should
have your input layer it goes into your
layer 1
layer 2 and then to the output layer and
it's useful for
simple classifier decoder models
and you can see down here we have the
model equals across sequential this is
the actual
code you can see how easy it is we have
a layer that's dense
your layer one has an activation they're
using the relu in this particular
example
and then you have your name layer one
layer dense relu
name layer 2 and so forth and they just
feed right into each other so it's
really easy just to stack them as you
can see here and it automatically takes
care of everything else for you
and then there's a functional model and
this
is really where things are at this is
new make sure you update your cross
or you'll find yourself running this
doing the functional model
you'll run into an error code because
this is a fairly new release
and he uses multi input and multi output
model
the complex model which forks into two
or more
branches and you can see here we have
our image inputs equals your cross input
shape equals 32 by 32 by 3.
you have your dense layers dan 64
activation relu
this should look similar to what you
already saw before
but if you look at the graph on the
right it's going to be a lot easier to
see what's going
on you have two different inputs
and one way you can think of this is
maybe one of those is a small image and
one of those is a full-sized image
and that feedback goes into you might
feed both of them into
one note because it's looking for one
thing and then only into
one node for the other one and so you
can start to get kind of an idea that
there's a lot of use
for this kind of split and this kind of
setup
we have multiple information coming in
but the information is very different
even though it overlaps
and you don't want to send it through
the same neural network
and they're finding that this trains
faster and is also has a better result
depending on how you split the data and
how you fork the models coming down
and so here we do have the two complex
models coming in
we have our image inputs which is a 32
by 32 by three or three channels or four
if you're having an alpha channel
you have your dense your layers dense is
64 activation
using the relu very common x equals
dense inputs x layers dense x64
activation equals relu
x outputs equals layers dense 10
x model equals cross model inputs equals
inputs
outputs equals outputs name equals
minced model
uh so we add a little name on there and
again this is this kind of split here
this is setting us up
to have the input go into different
areas
so if you're already looking at cross
you probably already have this answer
what are
neural networks but it's always good to
get on the same page and for those
people who don't fully understand neural
networks to dive into them a little bit
or do a quick overview
neural networks are deep learning
algorithms modeled after the human brain
they use multiple neurons which are
mathematical operations
to break down and solve complex mathical
problems
and so just like the neuron one neuron
fires in and it fires out to all these
other neurons or nodes as we call them
and eventually they all come down to
your output layer
and you can see here we have the really
standard graph input layer a hidden
layer and an output layer
one of the biggest parts of any
data processing is your data
pre-processing
so we always have to touch base on that
with a neural network like many of these
models
they're kind of when you first start
using them they're like a black box
you put your data in you train it
and you test it and see how good it was
and you have to pre-process that data
because bad data in is
bad outputs so in data pre-processing we
will create our own data
examples set with keras the data
consists of a clinical trial conducted
on 2100 patients
ranging from ages 13 to 100 with a
the patients under 65 and the other half
over 65 years of age
we want to find the possibility of a
patient experiencing side effects
due to their age and you can think of
this in today's world with
covid uh what's going to happen on there
and we're going to go ahead and
do an example of that in our live
hands-on like i said most of this you
really need to have hands-on to
understand
so let's go ahead and bring up our
anaconda and
open that up and open up a jupiter
notebook for doing the python code in
now if you're not familiar with those
you can use pretty much any of your
setups i just like those for doing demos
and
showing people especially shareholders
it really helps because it's a nice
visual
so let me go and flip over to our anacon
and the anaconda has a lot of cool two
tools they just added data lore and ibm
watson studio cloud into the anaconda
framework
but we'll be in the jupiter lab or
jupiter notebook
i'm gonna do jupiter notebook for this
because i use the lab for like large
projects with multiple pieces because
multiple tabs where the notebook will
work fine for what we're doing
and this opens up in our browser window
because that's how
jupiter dope how it's our jupiter
notebook is set to run
and we'll go under new create a new
python three
and uh it creates an untitled python
we'll go ahead and give this a title
and we'll just call this uh cross
tutorial
and let's change that to capital there
we go i'm going to just rename that
and the first thing we want to go ahead
and do is
get some pre-processing tools involved
and so we need to go ahead and import
some stuff for that like our numpy
do some random number generation um
i mentioned sklearn or your scikit if
you're installing sk learn
the sk learn stuff it's a sci kit you
want to look up
that should be a tool of anybody who is
doing data science if you're not if
you're not familiar with the sklearn
toolkit
it's huge but there's so many things in
there that we always go back to
and we want to go ahead and create some
train labels and train samples
for training our data
and then just a note of what we're we're
actually doing in here
let me go ahead and change this this is
kind of a fun thing you can do we can
change the code to markdown
and then markdown code is nice for doing
examples once you've already built this
our example data we're going to do
experimental
there we go experimental drug was tested
on 2100 individuals between 13 to 100
years of age
half the participants are under 65 and
95
of participants are under 65
experience no side effects well 95
percent of participants over 65 percent
experience side effects so that's kind
of where we're starting at
and this is just a real quick example
because we're going to do another one
with a little bit more
complicated information and so we want
to go ahead
and generate our setup
so we want to do for i and range and we
want to go ahead and
create if you look here we have random
integers
train the labels append so we're just
creating some random data
let me go ahead and just run that and so
once we've created our random data and
if you if
i mean you can certainly ask for a copy
of the code from simplylearn they'll
send you a copy of this or you can
zoom in on the video and see how we went
ahead and did our
train samples a pen
and we're just using this i do this kind
of stuff all the time
i was running a thing on uh they had to
do with errors following a bell shaped
curve
on a standard distribution error and so
what do i do i generate the data
on a standard distribution error to see
what it looks like and how my code
processes it
since that was the baseline i was
looking for in this
we're just doing uh generating random
data for our setup on here
and we could actually go in
print some of the data up let's just do
this print
we'll do train
samples and we'll just do the first
five pieces of data in there to see what
that looks like and you can see the
first five pieces of data in our train
samples is 49 85 41 68 19
just random numbers generated in there
that's all that is
and we generated significantly more than
that
let's see 50 up here 1000 yeah so
there's 1 000 here
1 000 numbers we generated and we could
also if we wanted to find that out we
could do a quick
print the length of it
and so or you could do a shape kind of
thing and if you're using numpy
although the link for this is just fine
and there we go it's actually 2100 like
we
said in the demo setup in there
and then we want to go ahead and take
our labels
oh that was our train labels we also did
samples didn't we
uh so we could also print
do the same thing
oop labels
and let's change this to
labels
and labels
and run that just to double check and
sure enough we have 2100
and they're labeled one zero one zero
one zero
i guess that's if they have symptoms or
not one symptoms
zero none and so we want to go ahead and
take our train labels and we'll convert
it into a numpy array
and the same thing with our samples and
let's go ahead and run that
and we also shuffle this is just a neat
feature you can do in
numpy right here put my drawing thing on
which i didn't have on earlier
um i can take the data and i can shuffle
it
uh so we have our so it's it just
randomizes it that's all that's doing
we've already randomized it so it's kind
of an overkill it's not really necessary
but if you're doing a larger package
where the data is coming in
and a lot of times it's organized
somehow and you want to randomize it
just to make sure that
that you know the input doesn't follow a
certain pattern
that might create a bias in your model
and we go ahead and create a scalar
the scalar range minimum max scalar
feature range zero to one
and then we go ahead and scale the uh
scaled train samples so we're going to
go ahead and fit and transform the data
so it's nice and scaled and that is the
age
so you can see up here we have 49 85 41.
we're just moving that so it's going to
be
between 0 and 1. and so this is true
with any of your neural networks
you really want to convert the data to 0
and 1. otherwise you create a bias
so if you have like a hundred creates a
bias versus
the math behind it gets really
complicated um
if you actually start multiplying stuff
there's a lot of multiplication addition
going on in there
that higher end value will eventually
multiply down and it will
have a huge bias as to how the model
fits it
and then it will not fit as well and
then one of the fun things we can do in
jupiter notebook
is that if you have a variable you're
not doing anything with it it's the last
one on the line
it will automatically print um
and we're just going to look at the
first five samples on here it's just
going to print the first five samples
and you can see here we go 0.9195.7
so everything's between 0 and 1. and
that just shows us that we scaled it
properly and it looks good
it really helps a lot to do these kind
of print ups halfway through
you never know what's going to go on
there
i don't know how many times i've gotten
down and found out that the data is sent
to me that i thought was scaled was not
and then i have to go back and track it
down and figure it out on there
so let's go ahead and create our
artificial neural network
and for doing that this is where we
start diving into
tensorflow and cross
tensorflow if you don't know the history
of tensorflow
it helps to jump into we'll just use
wikipedia
be careful don't quote wikipedia on
these things because you get in trouble
but it's a good place to start uh back
in 2011 google brain built disbelief as
a proprietary machine learning
setup tensorflow became the
open source for it uh so tensorflow was
a google product
and then it became uh open sourced and
now it's just become
probably one of the de factos when it
comes for neural networks
as far as where we're at so when you see
the tensorflow setup
it's got like a huge following there are
some other setups like
um the side kit under the sk learn has
their own little neural network
but the tensorflow is the most robust
one out there right now
and cross sitting on top of it makes it
a very powerful tool
so we can leverage both the cross
easiness in which we can build a
sequential
setup on top of tensorflow
and so in here we're going to go ahead
and do our input of tensorflow
and then we have the rest of this is all
cross here from
number two down uh we're going to
import from tensorflow the cross
connection
and then you have your tensorflow cross
models import sequential
it's a specific kind of model we'll look
at that in just a second if you remember
from the files that means it goes from
one layer to the next layer to the next
layer there's no funky splits or
anything like that
and then we have from tensorflow cross
layers we're going to import our
activation and our dense layer
and we have our optimizer atom
this is a big thing to be aware of how
you optimize
your data when you first do it atoms as
good as any
atom is usually there's a number of
optimizer out there there's about
uh there's a couple of main ones but
atom is usually assigned to
bigger data it works fine usually the
lower data does it just fine but atom is
probably the mostly used but there are
some more out there
and depending on what you're doing with
your layers your different layers might
have different activations on them
and then finally down here you'll see
our setup where we want to go ahead and
use the metrics
and we're going to use the tensorflow
cross metrics
for categorical cross entropy
so we can see how everything performs
when we're done that's all that is
a lot of times you'll see us go back and
forth between tensorflow and then
scikit has a lot of really good metrics
also for measuring these things
um again it's the end of the you know at
the end of the story how good does your
model do
and we'll go ahead and load all that and
then comes
the fun part um i actually like to spend
hours messing with these things and
four lines of code you're like oh you're
gonna spend hours on four lines of code
no we don't spend hours on four lines of
code that's not what we're talking about
when i say spend hours on four lines of
code
uh what we have here i'm gonna explain
that in just a second
we have a model and it's a sequential
model if you remember correctly we
mentioned the sequential up here
where it goes from one layer to the next
and our first layer
is going to be your input
it's going to be what they call dense
which is uh
usually it's just dense and then you
have your input and your activation
how many units are coming in we have 16
what's the shape what's the activation
and this is where it gets interesting
because we have in here relu
on two of these and soft max activation
on one of these
there are so many different options
for what these mean and how they
function how does the relu
how does the soft max function
and they do a lot of different things
we're not going to go into the
activations in here
that is what really you spend hours
doing is looking at these different
activations
and just some of it is just almost like
you're playing with it
like an artist you start getting a fill
for like a
inverse tangent activation or the 10h
activation
takes up a huge processing amount so you
don't see it a lot
yet it comes up with a better solution
especially when you're doing when you're
analyzing word documents
and you're tokenizing the words and so
you'll see this shift from one to the
other
because you're both trying to build a
better model and if you're
working on a huge data set it'll crash
the system
it'll just take too long to process
and then you see things like soft max
softmax
generates an interesting
setup where a lot of these when you talk
about rayleigh
it lets me do this rayloo there we go
relu has a setup where if it's less than
zero it's zero
and then it goes up and then you might
have what they call
lazy setup where it has a slight
negative to it so that the errors can
translate better
same thing with softmax it has a slight
laziness to it so that errors translate
better
all these little details make a huge
difference on your model
so one of the really cool things about
data science that i like
is you build your what they call you
build to fail
and it's an interesting design setup
oops i forgot the
end of my code here
the concept to build a fell is you want
the model
as a whole to work so you can test your
model out
so that you can do
you can get to the end and you can do
your let's see where was it
over shot down here you can test your
test out that the quality of your
setup on there and
see where did i do my tensorflow oh here
we go i did it was right above me
here we go we start doing your
cross-entropy and stuff like that
is you need a full functional set of
code
so that when you run it you can then
test your model out and say hey
it's either this model works better than
this model and this is why
and then you can start swapping in these
models and so when i say spend a huge
amount of time
on pre-processing data is probably 80 of
your programming time
um well between those two it's like 80
20. you'll spend a lot of time
on the models once you get the model
down once you get the whole code and the
flow down
uh set depending on your data your
models get more and more robust
as you start experimenting with
different inputs different data streams
and all kinds of things and we can do a
simple model summary here
uh here's our sequential here's a layer
output a parameter
this is one of the nice things about
cross is you just you can see right here
here's our sequential one model
boom boom boom boom everything's set and
clear and easy to read
so once we have our model built
the next thing we're going to want to do
is we're going to go ahead
and train that model
and so the next step is of course model
training
and when we come in here this a lot of
times it's just paired with the model
because it's so straightforward
it's nice to print out the model setup
so you can have a tracking
but here's our model the keyword
in cross is compile optimizer atom
learning rate another term right there
that we're just skipping right over
that really becomes the meat of
the setup is your learning rate so
whoops i forgot that i had an arrow but
i'll just underline it
a lot of times the learning rate set to
0.00
set to 0.01 uh depending on what you're
doing
this learning rate um can overfit and
underfit
uh so you'd want to look up i know we
have a number of tutorials out on
overfitting and under fitting
that are really worth reading once you
get to that point and understanding
and we have our loss sparse categorical
cross
entropy so this is going to tell keras
how far
to go until it stops and then we're
looking for metrics of accuracy
so we'll go ahead and run that and now
that we've compiled our model
we want to go ahead and run it fit it
so here's our model fit we have our
scale to train samples our train labels
our validation split in this case we're
going to use 10 percent of the data for
validation
batch size another number you kind of
play with
not a huge difference as far as how it
works
but it does affect how long it takes to
run and it can also affect the bias a
little bit
most of the time though a batch size is
between 10 to 100
depending on just how much data you're
processing in there we want to go ahead
and shuffle it
we're going to go through 30 epics and
put a verb rose of two let me just go
ahead and run this
and you can see right here here's our
epic here's our training
here's our loss now if you remember
correctly up here we set the loss
let's see where was it compiled our data
there we go loss so it's looking at the
sparse categorical cross entropy
this tells us that as it goes how how
how much um how how much does the
error go down is the best way to look at
that
and you can see here the lower the
number the better it just keeps going
down
and vice versa accuracy we want let's
see where's my accuracy
value accuracy at the end and you can
see
0.619 0.69 0.74
it's going up we want the accuracy would
be ideal if it made it all the way to
one
but we also the loss is more important
because
it's a balance you can have 100 accuracy
and your model doesn't work because it's
over
fitted again you won't look up over
fitting and underfitting models
and we went ahead and went through 30
epics
it's always fun to kind of watch your
code going
to be honest i usually uh uh
the first time i run it i'm like oh
that's cool i get to see what it does
and after the second time of running it
i'm like i'd like to just not see that
and you can repress those of course in
your code
uh repress the warnings in the printing
and so the next step is going to be
building a test set and predicting it
now
so here we go we want to go ahead and
build our test set
and we have just like we did our
training set
a lot of times you just split your your
initial set up
but we'll go ahead and do a separate set
on here and this
is just what we did above there's no
difference as far
as the randomness that we're using to
build this set on here
the only difference is that
we already did our scalar up here well
it doesn't matter because the
the data is going to be across the same
thing but this should just be just
transformed down here instead of fit
transform
because you don't want to refit your
data on your
testing data
there we go now we're just transforming
it because you never want to transform
the test
data easy to mistake to make especially
on an example like this where we're not
doing
you know we're randomizing the data
anyway so it doesn't matter too much
because we're not expecting something
weird
and then we went ahead and do our
predictions the whole reason we built
the model
is we take our model we predict and
we're going to do here's our x scale
data
batch size 10 verbose and now we have
our predictions in here
and we could go ahead and do a
oh we'll print
predictions and then i guess i could
just put down predictions in five so we
can look at the first five of the
predictions
and what we have here is we have our age
and uh the prediction on this age versus
what is what we think it's going to be
but what we think is going to they're
going to have
symptoms or not and the first thing we
notice is that's hard to read because we
really want to yes no
answer so we'll go ahead and just
round off the predictions using the arg
max
the numpy arg max for prediction so it
just goes to 001
and if you remember this is a jupiter
notebook so i don't have to put the
print i can just put in
rounded predictions and we'll just do
the first five
and you can see here zero one zero zero
zero so that's what the predictions are
that we have coming out of this
is no symptoms symptoms no symptoms
symptoms
no symptoms and just as we were talking
about at the beginning
we want to go ahead and take a look at
this there we go
confusion matrixes for accuracy check
most important part when you get down to
the end of the story
how accurate is your model before you go
and play with the model and see if you
can get a better accuracy out of it
and for this we'll go ahead and use the
scikit
the sk learn metrics site kit
being where that comes from import
confusion matrix
uh some iteration tools and of course a
nice matte plot library
that makes a big difference so it's
always nice to um
have a nice graph to look at a picture's
worth a
thousand words and then we'll go ahead
and
call it cm for confusion matrix why true
equals test labels why predict rounded
predictions
and we'll go ahead and load in our cm
and i'm not going to spend too much time
on the plotting
going over the different plotting code
you can spend like whole we have whole
tutorials
on how to do your different plotting on
there
uh what we do have here is we're gonna
do a plot confusion matrix
there's our cm our classes normalize
false title confusion matrix
c map is going to be in blues
and you can see here we have uh to the
nearest cmap
titles all the different pieces whether
you put tick marks or not
the marks the classes the color bar
so a lot of different information on
here as far as how we're doing the
printing of the
of the confusion matrix you can also
just dump the confusion matrix
into a seaborn and real quick get an
output
it's worth knowing how to do all this
when you're doing
a presentation to the shareholders you
don't want to do this on the fly you
want to take the time to make it look
really nice
like our guys in the back did and let's
go ahead and do this
forgot to put together our cm plot
labels
we'll go ahead and run that and then
we'll go ahead and call
the little the definition
for our mapping
and you can see here plot confusion
matrix that's our the
little script we just wrote and we're
going to dump our data into it
so our confusion matrix our classes
title confusion matrix and let's just go
ahead and run that
and you can see here we have our basic
setup
no side effects 195 had side effects
200 no side effects that had side
effects
so we predicted the 10 of them who
actually had side effects
and that's pretty good i mean i i don't
know about you but you know that's five
percent
error on this and this is because
there's 200 here that's where i get five
percent is
uh divide these both by by two and you
get five out of a hundred
uh you can do the same kind of math up
here not as quick on the flags it's 15
and 195.
not an easily rounded number but you can
see here where they have 15 people
who predicted to have no with the no
side effects but had side effects
kind of set up on there and these
confusion matrix
are so important at the end of the day
this is really where
where you show uh whatever you're
working on comes up and you can actually
show them hey this is how good we are
or not how messed up it is
so this was a uh i spent a lot of time
on some of the parts
but you can see here is really simple we
did the random generation of data
but when we actually built the model
coming up here
here's our model summary and we just
have
the layers on here that we built with
our model on this and then we went ahead
and trained it and ran the prediction
now we get a lot more complicated let me
flip back on over here because we're
going to do another
demo so that was our basic introduction
to it
we talked about the uh oops there we go
okay so implementing a neural network
with cross after creating our samples
and labels we need to create our cross
neural network model we will be working
with a sequential model which
has three layers and this is what we did
we had our input layer our hidden layers
and our output layers
and you can see the input layer coming
in
was the age factor we had our hidden
layer
and then we had the output are you going
to have symptoms or not
so we're going to go ahead and go with
something a little bit more complicated
training our model is a two-step process
we first compile our model and then we
train it in our training data set
so we have compiling compiling converts
the code into a form of understandable
by machine
we use the atom in the last example a
gradient descent algorithm to optimize a
model and then we trained our model
which means it let it learn on training
data
and i actually had a little backwards
there but this is what we just did
is we if you remember from our code we
just had let me go back here
here's our model that we created
summarized
we come down here and we compile it
so it tells it hey we're ready to build
this model and use it
and then we train it this is the part
where we go ahead and fit
our model and put that information in
here and it goes through the training on
there
and of course we scaled the data which
was really important to do
and then you saw we did the creating a
confusion matrix with keras
as we are performing classifications on
our data we need a confusion matrix to
check the results
a confusion matrix breaks down the
various misclassifications as well as
correct classifications to get the
accuracy
and so you can see here this is what we
did with the true positive
false positive true negative false
negative
and that is what we went over let me
just scroll down here
on the end we printed it out and you can
see we have a nice printout
of our confusion matrix with the
true positive false positive false
negative true negative
so the blue ones we want those to be the
biggest numbers because those are the
better side
and then we have our false predictions
on here
as far as this one so had no side
effects but we predicted
let's see no side effects predicting
side effects and vice versa if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
skill up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
now uh saving and loading models with
karass
we're going to dive into a more
complicated demo
and you can say oh that was a lot of
complication before well if you broke it
down
we randomized some data we created the
um cross setup we compiled it
we trained it we predicted and we ran
our matrix
uh so we're going to dive into something
a little bit more fun is we're going to
do a face mask
detection with cross so we're going to
build a cross model to check if a person
is wearing a mask or not
in real time and this might be important
if you're at the front of a store this
is something
today which is might be very useful as
far
as some of our you know making sure
people are safe
and so we're going to look at mask and
no mask and let's start with a little
bit on the data
and so in my data i have with a mask you
can see they just have a
number of images showing the people in
masks and again
if you want some of this information
contact simply learn
and they can send you some of the
information as far as people with and
without masks
so you can try it on your own and this
is just such a wonderful example of this
setup on here
so before i dive into the mass detection
talk about being in the current with a
covid and
seeing if people are wearing masks this
particular example i had to go ahead and
update to
a python 3.8 version uh it might run in
a three
seven i'm not sure i kind of skipped
three seven and
installed three eight uh so i'll be
running in a three python 3 8
and then you also want to make sure your
tensorflow is up to date
because the um they call functional
layers with that's where they split if
you remember correctly from back
oh let's take a look at this remember
from here the functional model
and a functional layer allows us to feed
in the different layers
into different you know different nodes
into different layers and split them
a very powerful tool very popular right
now
in the edge of where things are with
neural networks
and creating a better model so i've
upgraded to
python 3.8 and let's go ahead and open
that up and
go through our next example which
includes
multiple layers programming it to
recognize whether someone wears a mask
or not
and then saving that model so we can use
it in real time so we're actually almost
a full
end-to-end development of a product here
of course this is a very simplified
version
and it'd be a lot more to it you'd also
have to do like
recognizing whether it's someone's face
or not all kinds of other things go into
this
so let's go ahead and jump into that
code and we'll open up a new python
three
oops python three it's working on it
there we go um and then we want to go
ahead and
train our mask we'll just call this
train mask
and we want to go ahead and train mask
and
save it so it's it's
safe mask train mask detection
not to be confused with masking data a
little bit different we're actually
talking about a physical mask on your
face
and then from the cross standpoint we
got a lot of imports to do here
and i'm not going to dig too deep on the
imports
we're just going to go ahead and notice
a few of them uh
so we have in here we go alt
d there we go i have something to draw
with a little bit here
we have our uh image processing
and the image processing right here let
me underline that
uh deals with how do we bring images in
because most images are like a a square
grid and then each value in there has
three values for the three different
colors
cross and tensorflow do a really good
job of
working with that so you don't have to
do all the heavy listening and figuring
out what's going to go on
uh and we have the mobile net average
pooling 2d
um this again is how do we deal with the
images and pulling them
uh dropout's a cool thing worth looking
up
if you haven't when you as you get more
and more into cross and tensorflow
it will auto drop out certain nodes that
way you'll get a better
the notes just kind of die they find
that they actually
create more of a bias and help and they
also add processing time so to remove
them and then we have our flatten that's
where you take that
huge array with the three different
colors and you find a way to flatten it
so it's just a one dimensional array
instead of a two by two by three
dense input we did that in the other one
so that should look a little familiar
oops there we go our input our model
again these are things we had on the
last one here's our optimizer with our
atom
um we have some pre-processing on the
input
that goes along with bringing in the
data in uh
more pre-processing with image to array
loading the image
this stuff is so nice it looks like a
lot of work you have to import all these
different modules in here but the truth
is is it does everything for you
you're not doing a lot of pre-processing
you're letting the software do the
pre-processing
and we're going to be working with the
setting something to categorical again
that's just a conversion
from a number to a category zero one
doesn't really mean anything it's like
true false
label binarizer the same thing uh
we're changing our labels around and
then there's our train
test split classification report our
im utilities let me just go ahead and
scroll down here a notch for these
this is something a little different
going on down here this is not part of
the
tensorflow or the sklearn this is the
site kit setup
and tensorflow above the path
this is part of opencv
and we'll actually have another tutorial
going out with the opencv so if you want
to know more about opencv you'll get a
glance on it
in this software especially the net the
second piece when we reload up the data
and hook it up to a video camera we're
going to do that
on this round but this is part of the
opencv thing
you'll see cv2 is usually how that's
referenced
but the im utilities has to do with how
do you rotate pictures around and stuff
like that
and resize them and then the matplot
library for plotting because it's nice
to have a graph tells us how good
we're doing and then of course our numpy
numbers array and just the straight os
access wow so that was a lot of imports
uh like i said i'm not going to spend i
spent a little time going through them
but we didn't want to go too much into
them
and then i'm going to create some
variables that we need to go ahead and
initialize
we have the learning rate number of
epochs to train
for and the batch size and if you
remember correctly we talked about the
learning rate
to the negative 4.0001 um a lot of times
it's 0.001 or 0.001
usually it's in that variation depending
on what you're doing and how many epochs
and they kind of play with the epics
the epics is how many times we're going
to go through all the data
now i have it as two the actual setup is
for
20 and 20 works great the reason i have
it for two
is it takes a long time to process one
of the downsides of jupiter
is that jupiter isolates it to a single
kernel
so even though i'm on an eight core
processor
with 16 dedicated threads only one
thread is running on this
no matter what so it doesn't matter so
it takes a lot longer to run
even though tensorflow really scales up
nicely
and the batch size is how many pictures
do we load at once in process
again those are numbers you have to
learn to play with depending on your
data and what's coming in
and the last thing we want to go ahead
and do is there's a directory with a
data set we're going to run
and this just has images of mass and not
masks if we go in here you'll see data
set
um and then you have pictures with mess
they're just images of people with mass
on their face
uh and then we have the opposite let me
go back up here
without masks so it's pretty
straightforward they look kind of askew
because they tried to format them into
very similar uh
setup on there so they're they're mostly
squares you'll see some that are
slightly different on here
and that's kind of important thing to do
on a lot of these data sets
get them as close as you can to each
other and we'll we actually will run
in the in this processing of images up
here and the cross
layers and importing and dealing with
images it does such a wonderful job of
converting these that a lot of it we
don't have to do a whole lot with
so you have a couple things going on
there and so
we're now going to be this is now
loading the images
and let me see and we'll go ahead and
create
data and labels here's our
here's the features going in which is
going to be our pictures
and our labels going out and then for
categories
in our list directory directory and if
you remember i just flashed that at you
it had a
face mask or or no face mask those are
the two options
and we're just going to load into that
we're going to append the image itself
and the labels so we'll just create a
huge array
and you can see right now this could be
an issue if you had more data
at some point um thankfully i have a 32
gig hard drive or ram
even that you could do with a lot less
of that
probably under 16 or even 8 gigs would
easily load all this stuff
and there's a conversion going on in
here i told you about how we
are going to convert the size of the
image so it resizes all the images
that way our data is all identical the
way it comes in
and you can see here with our labels we
have without mask without mask without
mask
the other one would be with mask those
are the two that we have going in there
and then we need to change it to the one
not hot encoding
and this is going to take our um
up here we had was it labels and data
we want the labels to be categorical so
we're going to take labels and change it
to
categorical and our labels then equal a
categorical list
we'll run that and again if we do uh
labels and we just do the last or the
first 10
let's do the last 10 just because minus
10
to the end there we go just so we can
see where the other side looks like
we now have one that means they have a
mask one zero one zero
so on one being
they have a mask and zero no mask and if
we did this
in reverse i just realized that this
might not make sense if you've never
done this before
let me run this 0 1.
so zero is uh do they have a mask on
zero do they not have a mask on
one so this is the same as what we saw
up here without
mask one equals um the second
value is without mass so with mass
without mask
and that's just a with any of your data
processing
we can't really zero if you have a zero
one output
it causes issues as far as training and
setting it up so we always want to use a
one
hot encoder if the values are not actual
uh linear value or regression values or
not actual numbers
if they represent a thing and so now we
need to go ahead and do our train x test
x
train y test y um train split test data
and we'll go ahead and make sure it's
going to be uh random
and we'll take 20 of it for testing
and the rest for setting it up as far as
training their model this is something
that's become so cool when they're
training these set
they realize we can augment the data
what does
augment mean well if i rotate the data
around
and i zoom in i zoom out i rotate it
share it a little bit flip it
horizontally
fill mode as i do all these different
things to the data
it is able to it's kind of like
increasing the number
of samples i have uh so if i have all
these perfect samples
what happens when we only have part of
the face or the face is tilted sideways
or all those little shifts cause a
problem
if you're doing just a standard set of
data so we're going to create an
augment in our image data generator
which is going to rotate zoom and do all
kinds of cool things and this is worth
looking up this image
data generator and all the different
features it has
a lot of times i'll the first time
through my models i'll leave that out
because i want to make sure there's a
thing we call build to fail which is
just cool to know
you build the whole process and then you
start adding these different things
in uh so that you can better train your
model and so we go and run this and then
we're gonna load
um and then we need to go ahead and you
probably would have gotten an error if
you hadn't put this piece in right here
um i haven't run it myself because the
guys in the back did this
we take our base model and one of the
things we want to do is we want to do a
mobile net v2
and this we this is a big thing right
here include
the top equals false a lot of data comes
in with a label
on the top row so we want to make sure
that that
is not the case and then the
construction of the head of the model
that will be placed on the top of the
base model
we want to go ahead and set that up
and you'll see a warning here i'm kind
of ignoring the warning because it has
to do
with the size of the pictures
and the weights for input shape so
they'll switch things to defaults just
saying hey we're going to auto shape
some of this stuff for you
you should be aware that with this kind
of imagery we're already augmenting it
by moving it around and flipping it and
doing all kinds of things to it
so that's not a bad thing in this but
another data it might be if you're
working in a different domain
and so we're going to go back here and
we're going to have we have our base
model we're going to do our head model
equals our base model output
and what we got here is we have an
average pooling 2d
pool size 77 head model
head model flatten so we're flattening
the data
so this is all processing and flattening
the images and the pooling has to do
with some of the ways it can process
some of the data we'll look at that a
little bit when we get down to the lower
levels processing it
and then we have our dents we've already
talked a little bit about a dents just
what you think about
and then the head model has a drop out
of 0.5
what we can do with a drop out
the dropout says that we're going to
drop out a certain amount of nodes while
training
so when you actually use the model it
will use all the notes but this drops
certain ones out and it helps
stop biases from forming so it's really
a cool feature in here
they discovered this a while back we
have another dense mode
and this time we're using soft max
activation
lots of different activation options
here softmax is a real popular one for a
lot of things
and so is a relu
and you know there's we could do a whole
talk on activation formulas
and why what their different uses are
and how they work
when you first start out you'll you'll
use mostly the relu and the softmax for
a lot of them
just because they're they're some of the
basic setups it's a good place to start
and then we have our model equals model
inputs equals base model dot input
outputs equals head model so again we're
still building our model here
we'll go ahead and run that
and then we're going to loop over all
the layers in the base model and freeze
them
so they will not be updated during the
first training process
so for layer and base model layers
layers dot trainable equals
false a lot of times when you go through
your data
you want to kind of jump in part way
through
i i'm not sure why in the back they did
this for this particular example
but i do this a lot when i'm working
with series and
specifically in stock data i wanted to
iterate through the first
set of 30 data before it does anything
i would have to look deeper to see why
they froze it on this particular one
and then we're going to compile our
model so compiling the model
atom init layer decay
initial learning rate over epics and we
go ahead and compile our loss is going
to be the binary cross
entropy which we'll have that print out
optimizer for opt metrics is accuracy
same thing we had before not a huge jump
as far
as the previous code
and then we go ahead and we've gone
through all this and now we need to go
ahead and fit
our model uh so train the head of the
network print info training head
run now i skipped a little time because
you'll see the run time here is at 80
seconds per
epic it takes a couple minutes for it to
get through on a single kernel
one of the things i want you to notice
on here while we're well it's finishing
the processing
is that we have up here our augment
going on
so anytime the train x and trading y go
in
there's some randomness going on there
it is jiggling it around what's going
into our setup of course we're batch
sizing it
so it's going through whatever we set
for the batch values how many we process
at a time
and then we have the steps per epic the
train x
the batch size validation data here's
our
test x and test y where we're sending
that in
and this again is validation one of the
important things to know about
validation
is our when both
our training data and our test data have
about the same accuracy
that's when you want to stop that means
that our model isn't biased
if you have a higher accuracy on your uh
testing you know you've trained it and
your accuracy is higher on your actual
test data
then something in there is probably uh
has a bias and it's over fitted
so that's what this is really about
right here with the validation data
and validation steps
so it looks like it's let me go ahead
and see if it's done processing
it looks like we've gone ahead and gone
through two epics again you could run
this through about
20 with this amount of data and it would
give you a nice refined
model at the end we're going to stop at
2 because i really don't want to sit
around all afternoon and i'm running
this on a single thread
so now that we've done this we're going
to need to evaluate
our model and see how good it is and to
do that we need to go ahead and make our
predictions these are predictions
on our test x to see what it thinks are
going to be
so now it's going to be evaluating the
network and then we'll go ahead and go
down here
and we will need to turn the index in
because remember it's it's either zero
or one
it's a zero one zero one so you have two
outputs uh
not wearing uh wearing a mask not
wearing a mask
and so we need to go ahead and take that
argument at the end and
change those predictions to a 0 or 1
coming out and then to finish that off
we want to go ahead
and let me just put this right in here
and do it all in one shot
we want to show a nicely formatted
classification report so we can see what
that looks like on here
and there we have it we have our
precision uh it's 97
with the mask there's our f1 score
support without a mass 97 percent
so that's pretty high uh set up on there
you know
you three people are going to sneak into
the store who are without a mask
and thinks they have a mask and there's
going to be three people with a mask
that's going to flag the person at the
front to go oh hey look at this person
you might not have a mask
that's if i guess it's just set up in
front of a store um
so there you have it and of course one
of the other cool things about this
is if someone's walking in to the store
and you take multiple pictures of them
um you know this is just an it would be
a way of flagging and then you can take
that average of those
pictures and make sure they match or
don't match if you're on the back end
and this is an important step because
we're gonna this is just cool i love
doing this stuff
uh so we're going to go ahead and take
our model and we're going to
save it so model save massdetector.model
we're going to give it a name
we're going to save the format in this
case we're going to use the h5 format
and so this model we just programmed
has just been saved uh so now i can load
it up into say another program
what's cool about this is let's say i
want to have somebody work on the other
part of the program
well i just saved the model they upload
the model now they can
use it for whatever and then if i get
more information
and we start working with that at some
point
i might want to update this model and
make a better model
and this is true of so many things where
i take this model
and maybe i'm running a prediction on uh
making money for a company
and as my model gets better
i want to keep updating it and then it's
really easy just to push that out to the
actual
end user uh here we have a nice graph
you can see the
training loss and accuracy as we go
through the epics
we only did the you know only shows just
the one epic coming in here but you can
see right here as the
value loss train accuracy and value
accuracy
starts switching and they start
converging and you'll hear converging
this is a convergence they're talking
about when they say you're you're
i know when i work in the scikit with sk
learn
neural networks this is what they're
talking about a convergence
is our loss and our accuracy come
together
and also up here and this is why i'd run
it more than just two
epochs as you can see they still haven't
converged all the way
so that would be a cue for me to keep
going
but what we want to do is we want to go
ahead and create a new
python3 program
and we just did our train mask so now
we're going to go ahead and import that
and use it
and show you in a live action get a view
of
both myself in the afternoon along with
my
background of an office which is in the
middle still of reconstruction for
another month
and we'll call this a mask
detector
and then we're going to grab a bunch of
a few items coming in
we have our mobile net v2
import pre-processing input so we're
still going to need that
we still have our tensorflow image to
array we have our load
model that's where most of this stuff's
going on
this is our cv2 or opencv
again i'm not going to dig too deep into
that we're going to flash a little open
cv code at you
and we actually have a tutorial on that
coming out
our numpy array our im utilities which
is
part of the opencv or cv2 setup
and then we have of course time and just
our operating system so those are the
things we're going to go ahead and set
up on here
and then we're going to create this
takes just a moment
our module here which is going to do all
the heavy lifting
so we're going to detect and predict a
mask we have frame
face net mass net these are going to be
generated by our open
cv we have our frame coming in and then
we want to go ahead and
create a mask around the face it's going
to try to detect the face
and then set that up so we know what
we're going to be processing
through our model um
and then there's a frame shape here this
is just our
height versus width that's all hw stands
for
they've called it blob which is a cv2
dnn blob form image
frame so this is reformatting this frame
that's going to be coming in
literally from my camera and we'll show
you that in a minute that little piece
of code that
shoots that in here and we're going to
pass the blob through the network and
obtain the face detections
so face net dot set import blob
detections face net forward print
detections shape uh so this is this is
what's going on here this is that model
we just created
we're gonna send that in there and i'll
show you in a second where that is but
it's going to be
under face net and then we go ahead and
initialize our list of faces the
corresponding locations and the list of
predictions from our face mask network
we're going to loop over the detections
and this
is a little bit more work than you think
as far as looking for different faces
whatever the view of a crowd of faces
um so we're looping through the
detections and the shapes going through
here and probability associated with the
detection
here's our confidence of detections
we're going to filter out weak detection
by ensuring the confidence is greater
than the minimum
confidence so we've set it remember zero
to one so
0.5 would be our minimal confidence
probably is pretty good
and then we're going to put in compute
bounding boxes for the object
if i'm zipping through this it's because
we're going to do an open cv
and i really want to stick to just the
cross part
and so i'm just kind of jumping through
all this code you can get a copy of this
code
from simply learn and take it apart or
look for the opencv coming out
and we'll create a box the box sets it
around the image
ensure the bounding boxes fall within
the dimensions of the frame
so we create a box around what's going
to what we hope is going to be the face
extract the face roi convert it from bgr
to rgb channel
again this is an open cv issue not
really an issue but it has to do with
the order
i don't know how many times i've
forgotten to check the order colors when
working with opencv
because there's all kinds of fun things
when red becomes blue
and blue becomes red and we're going to
go ahead and resize it
process it frame it face frame
setup again the face the cvt color we're
going to convert it
we're going to resize it image to array
pre-process the input pin the face
locate face start x start y and x boy
that was just a huge amount
and i skipped over a ton of it but the
bottom line is we're building a box
around the face and that box because the
open cv
does a decent job of finding the face
and that box is going to go in there and
see hey does this person have a mask on
it
uh and so that's what that's what all
this is doing on here
and then finally we get down to this
where it says predictions equals mass
net dot predict faces
batch size 32 so these different
images where we're guessing where the
faces are then going to go
through and generate an array of faces
if you will
and we're going to look through and say
does this face have a mask on it
and that's what's going right here is
our prediction that's the big thing that
we're working for
and then we return the locations and the
predictions the location just tells
where on the picture it is
and then the prediction tells us what it
is
is it a mask or is it not a mask all
right so we've loaded that all up
so we're going to load our serialized
face detector model from
disk and we have our the path that it
was saved in obviously you're going to
put it in a different
path depending on where you have it or
however you want to do it and how you
saved it on the last one where we
trained it
uh and then we have our weights path um
and so finally our face net here it is
equals cb2.dnn.readnet
path weights path and we're going to
load that up on here
so let me go ahead and run that
and then we also need to i'll just put
it right down here i always hate
separating these things in there
and then we're gonna load the actual
mass detector model from disk this is
the
the model that we saved so let's go
ahead and run that on there also
so this is pulling on all the different
pieces we need for our model
and then the next part is we're to
create open up our video
and this is just kind of fun because
it's all part of the opencv
a video set up and we just put this all
in as one
there we go so we're going to go ahead
and open up our video
we're going to start it and we're going
to run it until we're done
and this is where we get some real like
kind of live action stuff which is fun
this is what i like working about with
images and videos
is that when you start working with
images and videos it's all like
right there in front of you it's visual
and you can see what's going on
so we're going to start our video
streaming this is grabbing our video
stream
source zero start that means it's
grabbing my main camera i have hooked up
um
and then you know starting video you're
gonna print it out here's our video
source equals zero start loop over the
frames from the video stream
oops a little redundancy there um let me
close
i'll just leave it that's how they
headed in the code so uh so while true
we're going to grab the frame from the
threaded video stream and resize it to
have the maximum width of 400 pixels
so here's our frame we're going to read
it from our
visual stream we're going to resize it
and then we have we're returning
remember we returned from the
our procedure the location and the
prediction so
detect and predict mask we're sending it
the frame
we're sending it the face net and the
mass net so we're sending all the
different pieces that say this is what's
going through
on here and then it returns
our location and predictions and then
for our box
and predictions in the location and
predictions
and the boxes is again this is an open
cv set that says hey this is a box
coming in from the location
because you have the two different
points on there
and then we're going to unpack the box
in predictions
and we're going to go ahead and do mask
without a mask equals prediction
we're going to create our label no mask
and create color if the label equals
mask
l0 225 and you know it's going to make a
lot more sense when i hit the run button
here
but we have the probability of the label
we're going to display the label and
bounding box rectangle
on the output frame and then we're going
to go ahead and show the output from the
frame
cv to im show frame frame and then the
key equals cp2 weight key one
we're just going to wait till the next
one comes through from our feed and
we're going to do this until
we hit the stop button pretty much so
you're ready for this to see if it works
we've distributed our
our model we've loaded it up into our
distributed
code here we've got a hooked into our
camera and we're going to go ahead and
run it
and there it goes it's going to be
running and we can see the data coming
down here
and we're waiting for the pop-up
and there i am in my office with my
funky head sat on
and you can see in the background my
unfinished wall and it says up here
no mask oh no i don't have a mask on
i wonder if i cover my mouth what would
happen
you can see my no mask
goes down a little bit i wish i brought
a mask into my office uh it's up at the
house
but you can see here that this says you
know there's a 95 98
chance that i don't have a mask on and
it's true i don't have a mask on right
now
and this could be distributed this is
actually an excellent little piece of
script that you could start you know you
install somewhere on a video feed on a
on a security camera or something
and then you'd have this really neat
setup saying hey do you have a mask on
when you enter a store
or a public transportation or whatever
it is where they're required to wear a
mask
let me go ahead and stop that
now if you want a copy of this code
definitely give us a hauler
we will be going into opencv in another
one so i skipped a lot of the opencv
code in here as far as going into detail
really focusing on
the cross saving the model uploading the
model
and then processing a streaming video
through it so you can see it that the
model works we actually have this
working model that hooks into
the video camera which is just pretty
cool
a lot of fun so i told you we're going
to dive in and really roll up our sleeve
and do a lot of coding today
we did the basic demo up above for just
pulling in across and then we went into
a cross
model where we pulled in data to see
whether someone was wearing a mask or
not
so very useful in today's world as far
as a fully running application
and with that we have come to the end of
this video on tensorflow and keras
i hope you all found it informative and
interesting if you have any
questions leave them in the comment
section down below and our team will
solve
all of your queries stay safe and keep
learning